I'm alone, but a pity I won't be soon in New York City when I see you.
我独自一人，不过等我到纽约见到你时，就不会孤单了。
Please permit me to tell you everything in Atlantic City.
请允许我在大西洋城把一切都告诉你。
Well, hello friends.
嗨，大家好。
Hello, it's Josh Radner.
大家好，我是乔希·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hey Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嘿，乔希。
Hey, we're talking about how I met your mother.
嘿，我们在聊《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
That's a show we made together from 2005 to 2014.
那是我们从2005年到2014年一起制作的一档节目。
We did 208 episodes of that show, people still watching, people still love it, people still talk about it.
我们为那部剧制作了208集，人们至今仍在观看，依然喜爱它，也依然在谈论它。
We're still talking about it.
我们现在还在谈论它。
We're now edging up close to the age of the older Ted Narrator character.
我们现在正渐渐逼近剧中老年叙述者老泰德的年纪。
So we are looking back on this time, this younger time in our lives when we made a TV show about a younger time in these people's lives.
所以我们正在回首这段时光，我们生活中更年轻的时光，当时我们制作了一部关于这些人更年轻时期的电视剧。
the meta situation here, nose, no bounds.
这里的套娃属性，简直无极限。
But today we are talking about episode, what episode is this episode?
但今天我们要聊的是某一集，这一集到底是哪一集？
Episode eight, it's called Atlantic City.
第八集，名字叫《大西洋城》。
It was written by...
它的编剧是……
This was written by Maria Ferrari, who was our writer's assistant at the time, and he went on to become a writer on How Much Mother, and has gone on to a bunch of really cool things since then.
这集的编剧是玛丽亚·法拉利，她当时是我们的编剧助理，后来她成了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的编剧，从那以后还参与了许多非常酷的项目。
And she wrote this one, I think this was her first episode, I think.
她写了这一集，我想这应该是她的第一集吧，我猜。
Boy, no, wait, there may have been one in season one.
天哪，不对，等等，第一季里可能也有一集。
I'm having a moment.
我脑子有点短路了。
You were just talking about Waldo Regading and this is just proof of it.
你刚才还在说沃尔多·雷加丁，这就是证据。
But it's a huge thing.
但这可是一件大事。
You remember what we were talking about Courtney had, Courtney Kang had been on like four different shows that all got canceled before her episode aired.
你还记得我们之前聊过柯特妮吗，柯特妮·康曾参与过大概四部不同的剧集，结果在她的剧集播出前全都被砍了。
So I think return to the shirt, right, was her first episode from season one that had ever made it onto the air.
所以我认为《重回衬衫》，没错，是她第一季中唯一成功播出的剧集。
I mean, there's a weird thing in Hollywood where you can be like shooting pilots and shooting episodes of canceled shows and no one ever see, you can't tell your hometown friends like, here's my episode, or I'm gonna be on TV, but you're working.
我是说，好莱坞有一种奇怪的现象，你可能会一直在拍试播集、拍那些被砍了的剧集，但根本没人看得到，你甚至不能跟家乡的朋友说：“这是我写的剧集”或者“我要上电视了”，但你确实在工作。
You're like getting your health insurance.
你还在赚取医疗保险。
You're working in Hollywood.
你在好莱坞工作。
It's weird.
这真的很奇怪。
It used to be a very, that part's weird.
过去确实很奇怪，那部分真的很怪。
Another part that's gotten even weirder is becoming a writer's assistant and our script coordinator, that little mini department in the writing department of a TV show, that used to be kind of the most logical way to become a writer, right?
另一个变得更奇怪的现象是，成为一名编剧助理或剧本统筹——也就是电视剧编剧部门里那个小小的工作组，这过去可以说是成为编剧最合乎逻辑的途径，对吧？
Every other way requires some bit of magic or miracle, But the work your way up way is to get in a writer's room and be in there and learn and soak things up and hope that you get an opportunity to write a script on that show and move into being a writer maybe on that show or another show, your next show, past it, you're gonna be a writer on that show.
其他每种途径都需要一点魔法或奇迹，但通过努力往上爬的方法就是进入编剧室，呆在那里，学习、吸收各种知识，并祈祷自己能有机会在那部剧里写一个剧本，然后转正成为那部剧或者下一部剧的编剧，超越过去，你就会成为那部剧的正式编剧。
It has gotten so hard to do that now.
现在要做到这一点已经变得太难了。
There are so few shows, the rooms have gotten so small, the episode orders of TV shows, like these little streaming shows or eight episodes, 10 episodes, so small.
剧集越来越少，编剧室变得越来越小，电视剧的单季集数——比如这些流媒体的小短剧只有8集、10集——少得可怜。
So it was already really hard to do when writers on our show like Matt Coon and Maria Ferrari, Jenny Hendricks, like writers assistants had graduated to then write himium episodes and get on staff.
所以，在20年前，像我们剧组的马特·库恩、玛丽亚·法拉利、珍妮·亨德里克斯这样的编剧助理想要晋升为分集编剧并进入核心编剧团队就已经很难了。
That was pretty hard to do 20 years ago.
20年前这相当不容易。
It's exponentially harder to do now.
现在要做到这一点则要困难呈指数级上升。
It really is, we get asked Carter and I all the time, like, well, what's the path?
确实如此，我和卡特经常被问到：“那么，通往这条路的途径是什么？”
And we're like, it started off hard and it got harder.
我们的回答是：“一开始就很难，后来变得更难了。”
So God bless you if you're out there, do it.
所以，如果你正在外面闯荡并坚持这么做，老天保佑你。
If you can get into a room and be a writers assistant, still a great way to do it.
如果你能进入编剧室当一名编剧助理，这依然是一条绝佳的途径。
But there aren't as many 22 episode opportunities to do that.
但像以前那种22集的剧集机会已经没那么多了。
Well, it's hard, I think, to reinvent the wheel.
嗯，我认为要重新发明车轮是很难的。
I think that a lot of times we try to pull apart television or pull apart the model of how things have been done.
我觉得很多时候我们试图解构电视，或者解构以往行之有效的模式。
And for a while, it looks like, oh, we discovered a new way.
有一段时间，看起来像是“哦，我们发现了一条新途径”。
But what you're seeing is all these different streamers, all the now they have ads, now they're not doing them.
但你看到的是所有这些不同的流媒体平台，现在它们推出了广告，过一会儿又取消了。
They're not dropping all the episodes or doing it once a week.
它们有时会一次性放出所有剧集，有时又改成一周播出一集。
It's like they're inventing television.
这就像它们在重新发明电视一样。
They're bundling the streamers together.
它们把各种流媒体服务打包在一起。
Suddenly, you have cable.
突然之间，你又回到了有线电视时代。
It's ridiculous.
这太荒谬了。
they're just going back to the model of, because there was something satisfying up there.
它们只是在走回老模式，因为过去的某些东西确实能带来满足感。
I think the reason everyone freaked out over the pit was not just because it was a great show, which it was, it was because it was an old model, dusted off and made new again, but it was like every week, a procedure, following a group of people in a workplace, like there was just something very satisfying about it.
我觉得每个人都为《急诊室的故事》疯狂的原因，不仅仅是因为它是一部伟大的剧集——它的确是，而是因为它是一种老模式，被拂去灰尘重新焕发了生机；它就像每周播出的单元剧，讲述一群人在职场中的故事，这种模式本身就带有一种非常令人满足的东西。
And I think like we can try to reinvent the wheel, but ultimately like, I think they did crack the code of what makes TV work, and we're just gonna come back to it, hopefully.
所以我觉得，我们可以尝试重新发明车轮，但归根结底，我认为他们当年确实破解了电视运作的密码，而我们希望最终能回归这种模式。
Yeah.
是的。
And podcasting is radio.
播客其实就是广播。
Like we've put new names, we've put new, we're doing a radio show.
我们只是换了新名字，换了新说法，但我们其实在做一档广播节目。
That's what we're doing.
这就是我们在做的事。
Like we're just slapping names on shit.
我们只是给这些破事贴上新的标签。
Like it's new, it's not new.
就好像它是崭新的，其实根本不新。
So this episode of Atlantic City was episode eight of season two.
所以《大西洋城》这一集是第二季的第八集。
Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的。
What was the air date?
播出日期是什么时候？
This aired on, yes.
这一集的播出日期是，没错。
This aired on November 13th, 2006.
这一集的播出日期是2006年11月13日。
Ooh.
哦。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
Give us a, yeah.
给我们一个……对。
I would wager there's always a little extra beat after the Alex says the date where we just briefly contemplate our own desk.
我敢打赌，每当亚历克说完日期后，总会多出一小段空白，我们会在那短短的一瞬间陷入对自我死亡的沉思。
Like the Grim Reaper just briefly appears.
就像死神突然短暂地现身了一样。
No, that little brat, that little pause is us going.
不，那个小鬼般的、短暂的停顿其实是我们心里在想：
It's coming.
它要来了。
That's coming.
那一天要来了。
You can't see it, but there's a grip to the pod.
你可能看不见，但录播室里其实潜伏着一个死神。
There's Grim Reaper behind both Craig and I.
克雷格和我身后都有一个死神。
It's Matt Coon dressed as the Grim Reaper.
那是打扮成死神的马特·库恩。
The razor sharp size of the Grim Reaper just briefly appears and then it goes off the screen.
死神那把极其锋利的镰刀一闪而过，然后就退出了屏幕。
Here we are.
我们开始吧。
So comedy, comedy.
接下来聊聊喜剧。
Craig, tell us, give us a little synopsis of what this episode is.
克雷格，给我们简单概括一下这一集讲了些什么吧。
Yeah, this is a road trip episode.
好的，这是一集公路旅行剧。
This is the whole gang on a road trip, which I love.
这是整群人一起踏上公路旅行，我非常喜欢。
And we hadn't really done.
而且我们之前并没有怎么拍过这种情节。
Everybody just goes to a whole other city.
所有人都直接去了一个全新的城市。
We'd flirted with some of Philadelphia in season one, but this is Marshall and Lily get the idea to go get married today.
我们在第一季时曾稍微涉足过费城，但这一集是马歇尔和莉莉突然萌生了今天就去结婚的想法。
And it's in part so that Lily can dodge the judgment of Marshall's family.
部分原因是为了让莉莉逃避来自马歇尔家人的评判。
I forgot that sort of motivating spark.
我都快忘了这个最初的动机了。
This is an episode about dodging the repercussions of a breakup and not wanting to be in front of everybody who was angry at you, that there was this breakup, and then realizing in the end, you have to face that.
这一集讲的是如何逃避分手的余波，以及不想面对那些对你们分手感到愤怒的人，但最后你还是会意识到，你必须去面对它。
This is Lily's journey to escaping a wedding only to come back around and realize she does want a wedding.
这是莉莉的一段旅程：她试图逃离一场婚礼，最终却兜兜转转地意识到，她其实还是想要一场婚礼。
It's funny, we were just talking about trying to reinvent TV and realizing the models there.
有趣的是，我们刚才还在讨论试图重新发明电视，却发现原有的模式一直都在。
It's almost like they try to escape a big part of a wedding, which is family weirdness, confrontation, things not going according to plan.
这就像他们试图逃避婚礼中最宏大的一部分——也就是家庭的古怪氛围、对峙以及计划赶不上变化的情况。
You say, let's avoid all that.
你可能会说：“让我们避开所有这些麻烦吧。”
Ultimately, you're like, that's actually part of it.
但最终你会发现，其实这也是其中的一部分。
That's part of the the ritual, the stepping in, you know, you know, you're uniting two families.
这是仪式的一部分，是跨入新阶段的一部分，你知道的，你要将两个家族紧密相连。
Like, it's there's gonna be hiccups ahead, you know.
所以，前方肯定会有一些波折，你知道的。
Okay, so I had a couple memories of this episode.
好吧，我对这一集还有一些记忆。
I remember, so we've laid out the model of how the show works.
我记得——我们之前已经梳理过节目的运作模式了。
So we would get the the table redraft on a Friday when we were shooting the final, you know, we would read it on a Monday for like 45 minutes or an hour.
我们通常在拍摄最后一幕的那个星期五拿到剧本的围读稿，你知道的，我们会在周一花大约45分钟到1个小时的时间来读剧本。
There'd be a nice fruit and bagels and cream cheese.
现场会有美味的水果、百吉饼和奶油干酪。
And then we would go home.
然后我们就可以回家了。
You guys would get studio network notes, rewrite it.
你们会拿到电视台的剧本意见，然后进行重写。
Some days we would get the rewrite kind of quick, other times it would get it later at night if there was more significant changes.
有时候我们很快就能拿到重写版，如果有重大修改的话，有时候会拿到比较晚。
We'd come in the next day, get it on its feet with Pam, and then do a run through for the studio network.
第二天我们来到片场，和帕姆一起把剧本排练起来，然后为电视台高层进行一次串排。
You guys would get another round of notes and then do another rewrite before we shot Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
你们会收到另一轮意见，然后在我们周三、周四、周五正式拍摄之前再进行一次重写。
Now, my memory of this one is that there was more massive rewriting, there was more massive rewriting being done on this episode than anyone I had remembered up until that point.
现在，我对这一集的记忆是，有大量的大规模重写，这一集进行的大规模重写比我记忆中之前任何一集都要多。
Is that, is my memory correct?
是这样吗？我的记忆准确吗？
I think we were, yeah, that, God, I didn't remember that.
我想是的，天哪，我都不记得了。
It's funny that you, it's like blocking out the labor pan so far.
真搞笑，这就像是把生孩子的痛苦给选择性失忆了一样。
Like, yeah, I didn't remember that, but now that you mention it, I think that's right.
对啊，我不记得了，但经你这么一提，我觉得好像是这样。
I think we didn't, we didn't know how to write an episode where the whole gang's like, let's go to a whole different city and keep everyone's little thread alive and make sure it's all satisfying.
我想我们当时不知道该怎么写这样一集：主角团所有人去到一个完全不同的城市，还要维持每个人各自的小支线，并确保所有支线都令人满意。
Everyone has enough to do.
每个人都有足够的事情可做。
I think it was more challenging to write or we were more out of our comfort zone and putting that one together.
我觉得写这一集更具挑战性，或者说我们在创作这一集时更觉得脱离了舒适区。
I think that's right.
我觉得是这样的。
Did that ever alarm you guys as a cast Josh, when you would see, when you'd go to bed and the script hasn't shown up even on email, I think there used to be hard copies delivered and it hasn't even been fucking emailed out.
乔什，作为演员，当你们看到——准备睡觉了，邮件里还没收到剧本，我记得以前还会送纸质剧本过来，结果这次连个鬼影的邮件都没发出来——这种情况曾经让你们感到恐慌吗？
You go, this is a disaster.
你会想：“这下完蛋了。”
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，是播客节目《Hyper-Fixed》的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的烦恼：“我30岁了，但很害怕在纽约开车。”
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：“为什么当我挂倒车档时，没办法调节汽车音响的音量？”
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏体制。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
You'd kind of glance at your computer or phone, it ended up being phone.
你可能会扫一眼电脑或手机，最后基本上都是看手机。
And you know, sometimes it'd come through at 8, 7, 30, 9, but some nights you'd be going to sleep not that early and you'd be like, whoa, that script still hasn't come through.
你知道的，有时剧本会在8点、7点半、9点发来，但有些晚上，你睡得并不算早，然后你就会想：“哇，剧本怎么还没发来。”
And you'd have an image of like you and Carter and the writers like still there, you know, like still pulling like a later night.
你的脑海中就会浮现出你、卡特和编剧们还在那儿的画面，你知道的，就像还在熬夜加班一样。
Tuesday's were tough because the math of a Tuesday wouldn't add up in a production week.
周二总是很难熬，因为周二的时间怎么算在制作周里都不够用。
It just didn't add up because you the act you the cast, the actors, you know them.
时间根本不够用，因为你们——作为演员的你们，你们懂的。
You're one of them.
你就是他们中的一员。
You guys would need the whole morning to rehearse to put it on its feet to block it out on its feed, right?
你们需要整个上午来排练，把它搬上舞台，在舞台上进行走位，对吧？
You did like a little bit of that maybe Monday afternoon, maybe, but then Tuesday you got there.
也许周一下午你们会排练一小会儿，也许吧，但到了周二你们去到片场。
There's this whole rewritten script from the Monday table read post table read rewrite that whole rewrite on Monday night.
这里有一份全新的剧本，这是根据周一桌读会之后的修改重写而成的，也就是周一晚上进行的那次整体重写。
Now you're on Tuesday, you're Tuesday morning, you and Pam, you're going through all the scenes, all the sets, all the swing sets, you're blocking it out, you're seeing what these scenes feel like.
现在到了周二，周二上午，你和帕姆在过所有的场景、所有的布景、所有的转场布景，你们在走位，在感受这些场景的氛围。
And you have till lunch to do that on Tuesday.
周二你们只有到午饭前的时间来做这些。
And then you take a little food break, and then we do the run through for the studio on the network, which is on our soundstage, walking from set to set, acting it all out.
然后你们吃个简餐，接着我们就为电视台高层进行串排，地点就在我们的摄影棚里，从这个布景走到那个布景，把整集演一遍。
And then you guys leave, the cast leaves, so that maybe you go to wardrobe, whatever you do, like if there, you know, probably you mostly just went home at that point.
然后你们就收工了，演员们离开了，也许你们去试衣间，或者做点别的，如果你懂的，可能大部分时候那种情况下你们就直接回家了。
And then we begin that rewrite.
然后我们就开始进行重写。
What is it now?
现在几点了？
It's three o'clock, you know, whatever it is, mid-afternoon, afternoon.
下午三点，你知道的，不管几点，反正就是下午。
And if you got a lot of notes, you just do backtrack the math.
如果你收到了很多修改意见，你一算时间。
You go, we are gonna be here late.
你就会想：我们今晚得待到很晚了。
We're lucky.
我们挺幸运的。
We didn't have a ton of those.
我们没遇到太多这种情况。
It was always a little bit late on Tuesday, just cause I explain the math is so rough on that day.
周二的进度总是有点赶，只是因为我解释过，那一天的工时安排实在是太紧张了。
But this one and I hasten to point out through no fault of Maria Ferrari, who's a wonderful writer.
但这一集——我急忙要指出的是——这绝对不是玛丽亚·法拉利（Maria Ferrari）的问题，她是一位非常优秀的编剧。
We might just, my suspicion or my half memory is we didn't, we didn't have everybody, all five characters of beginning, middle, and end, like whatever their funny little runner is, maybe we're missing some payoffs, maybe we didn't have like the way it all came together at the end, there was something missing that we hadn't figured out.
我们可能只是——我的猜测或者说我模糊的记忆是，我们当时没有把所有人都安排妥当，没有把所有五个角色的起承转合都理顺，比如他们各自那些滑稽的小支线，也许我们漏掉了一些精彩的回收，也许我们还没有想好最后一切是如何串联在一起的，有什么东西缺失了，是我们还没想出来的。
And I like to think that was rare.
我愿意相信这种情况是很少见的。
You know, it's interesting that you guys, you guys as writers got a little bit disoriented by not being in the apartment in the bar.
你知道的，很有意思的是，你们——你们作为编剧，因为不在公寓和酒吧里而感到有点迷失方向。
Like, it's almost like taking your family on vacation and you're like, I don't know how to do anything.
就像是带着家人去度假，然后你会想：我什么都不会做了。
You're like, how do you close the child in Atlantic City versus, you know?
就像你在大西洋城该怎么结束那场戏，对比一下（在酒吧）你知道的？
So you were at sea, which is funny because it's the episode ends at sea.
所以你们当时就像在大海中迷失方向一样，说来也搞笑，因为这一集的结尾正是在大西洋城的海上。
You guys were, I think like there were new rules.
你们当时，我觉得就好像有了新的规则。
Each episode has its own internal logic, right?
每一集都有它自己的内在逻辑，对吧？
And you guys, I think it took you a little bit to figure out the one bit in this episode that I remember I think was there from start to finish, was Barney and the weird gambling thing that he understands that they can't understand, and that Marshall understands.
而你们，我觉得你们花了一点时间才弄明白这一集里的某个梗，我记得这个梗从头到尾都在，那就是巴尼和那个他懂而其他人不懂的奇怪赌博游戏，以及马修也懂。
I think that I remember being in the table draft and going all the way through.
我记得桌读剧本时就有这个情节，并且一直保留到了最后。
Well, what's funny is on how I met your mother, whenever we tried to do something that another show would think of as simpler, like, oh, great, everyone's all together, just big long scenes with everyone together, going through a big forest.
有趣的是，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中，每当我们尝试做一些其他剧集会觉得更简单的事情时，比如，哦太好了，所有人都聚在一起，只要拍一大段所有人都在一起的长镜头，穿过一片大森林。
In a limo.
坐在一辆加长豪华轿车里。
Like the limo, it's exactly what I'm thinking of.
就像加长轿车那一集，这正是我脑子里想的。
We always somehow fucked it up.
我们总能莫名其妙地把它搞砸。
We always, like the simple thing, it's like missing a free throw in basketball.
我们总是，就像这种简单的东西，就像在篮球比赛中罚丢一个球一样。
It's like the simple thing always was hard.
这就好像简单的东西总是很难做好。
We'd much rather be spinning 45 plates at once, cramming like 80 scenes in a 20 minute boom, boom, boom, boom.
我们宁愿同时转动45个盘子，在20分钟里塞进80个场景，砰，砰，砰，砰。
When everyone's just standing there playing out big long scenes together, that was always hard.
当所有人都只是站在那里一起演很长的对手戏时，那总是很难。
And the answer was usually find ways to get in there and chop it up and do flashbacks and the gambling game and like all, We just didn't want to go too long having to do big long scenes, not that you guys are great as a group in big long scenes, but writing-wise, I think we always got up in our heads with it.
而解决办法通常是找方法切入进去，把它剪碎，加入闪回和那个赌博游戏之类的所有东西。我们就是不想把戏拍得太长，必须去演很长很长的对手戏，倒不是说你们作为团队不擅长演长戏，但从写作角度来看，我觉得我们总是把事情想得太复杂。
It wasn't the strength of our show.
这不是我们这部剧的强项。
The strength in big long scenes were those emotional scenes in the third act.
长对手戏的强项是第三幕中那些充满情感的场景。
That's where it would breathe more and where it's length and uninterrupted, where it wasn't so choppy.
那是剧集能够更多地呼吸、能够有连贯性和不被打断的地方，不会显得那么零碎。
That's where a lot of the payoffs for the episodes came, but you had earned it by having a lot more fractured storytelling up until those moments.
剧集的大多数高潮和情感回报都在那里，但在此之前，你必须通过更加碎片化的叙事来为之奠定基础。
Yeah, and I think finding that emotional depth of like, what is this episode really about?
是的，而且我觉得要找到那种情感深度，比如：这一集到底讲的是什么？
Because to us, I think our mistake was like, it's just a fun romp to Atlantic City, it's a farce, but when we're missing that emotional grounding piece, which I think we realized was, Lily's trying to dodge these repercussions and realize it's like, and I like that little running thing where the judge and the ship captain senses their ambivalence.
因为对我们来说，我觉得我们的错误在于，会觉得这只是一次去大西洋城的有趣出游，是一场闹剧，但当我们缺少了那个情感基石时——我想我们意识到，那其实是莉莉在试图逃避这些后果，并意识到这就好比……我挺喜欢那个贯穿始终的小桥段：法官和船长敏锐地察觉到了他们的游移不定。
There's even these strangers, they've just met her.
甚至还有这些陌生人，他们才刚认识她。
I'll kind of like, what are you trying to run away from here a little bit?
也会有点像是在说：你们在这里到底想逃避什么呢？
And once we realized that's what this was about, then it made sense.
一旦我们意识到这一集的内核是关于这个的，一切就都说得通了。
But maybe we realized that Tuesday night at 10 p.m.
但也许我们是在周二晚上十点才意识到这一点的。
And that's why we were there until three in the morning.
这就是为什么我们那天晚上一直待到凌晨三点。
You know, Craig, I actually thought of something that I don't know that we've ever talked about.
你知道吗，克雷格，我其实想到了一个事，我不知道我们以前有没有聊过。
You and I, I don't know.
你和我，我不知道。
But didn't, before the episode aired, and I don't remember if we were there for some convention or something, but we as a cast before, no, no, no.
但是，在这一集播出之前——我不记得我们当时是不是去参加什么会议之类的，但我们作为演员在那之前，不，不，不。
This is before the show even aired.
这是在剧集播出之前。
This is what made me think of this because of the casino and everything.
因为赌场和那些事，让我突然想到了这个。
We all went to Vegas.
我们所有人都去了拉斯维加斯。
Do you remember we us going to Vegas?
你还记得我们去拉斯维加斯吗？
The cast or the cast and you and me?
是演员们，还是演员们加上你和我？
You were there.
你在场。
Like me and Carter, me and me and Carter.
就像我和卡特，我和——我和卡特。
We were, yeah, I think we did to like MIPCOM or something.
我们去了，对，我想我们是去参加MIPCOM还是什么的。
It was like, I think, yeah.
大概是吧，我想是的。
Thing we went to.
那是我们去过的一个活动。
Yeah, there was, that's right.
对，没错，确实有这回事。
I didn't, we didn't appear on stage with you.
我没有——我们没有和你们一起在台上。
You guys did your own thing.
你们做你们自己的事。
And I think we were on stage with Dana Walden or Edd or something as like a writing panel.
我想我们是和达娜·瓦尔登（Dana Walden）或埃德（Ed）他们一起在台上，作为一个编剧小组。
But we were, it was pre, it wasn't airing yet, I think.
但我们在那儿的时候，那是开播前，我觉得剧还没播呢。
So we were kind of anonymous in Vegas.
所以我们在拉斯维加斯基本上算是默默无闻。
But I remember, and we should confirm this with Kobe, we were all gathered around a roulette table.
但我记得——我们应该跟科比（Kobe）确认一下——我们全都围在一个轮盘赌桌旁边。
And we had to go, I think they gave us like a certain amount of money to gamble with.
我们得去，我想他们给了我们一定数量的钱来赌博。
And I don't, I should just say, I don't love gambling, I don't have the thing.
我不知道，我必须说明的是，我并不喜欢赌博，我没有那种赌徒心态。
Like I don't, it makes me just mostly anxious to gamble.
我不喜欢，赌博只会让我感到焦虑。
Kobe threw like on a lark, just threw a ton of money on like a number, like one number.
科比一时兴起，把一大笔钱全押在了一个数字上，就押了一个数字。
And she hit it, like she hit the roulette wheel.
然后她就中了，就像她打中了轮盘赌一样。
And I remember her face like we all we all cheered in a way that we you saw us throughout the series when the five of Us like would get excited Like she she made I don't remember how much money she got but she like It was like a very cool moment in a casino with all of us.
我记得她的脸，我们当时都——某种程度上我们都欢呼了，就像你在整部剧里看到我们五个兴奋起来的那样。她——我不记得她赢了多少钱，但她——这就像是在赌场里我们大家一起经历的一个非常酷的时刻。
So maybe we were Drawing on that when we go to fake Atlantic City because we had been in Rio Vegas I was not there for that Carter and I and maybe we were all there Yeah, I want to ask Kobe if she remembers that because I'm sure she does because it was like one of those things where you're like How do you get the number on the roulette wheel like it was crazy?
所以也许我们在假装去大西洋城时借鉴了这一点，因为我们去过里约/维加斯——我当时不在场，卡特和我，也许我们都在场？是的，我想问科比她是否还记得，因为我确信她记得，因为那是那种会让你觉得“你怎么能在轮盘赌上押中数字的？”的事情，太疯狂了。
Yeah?
是吗？
There's no skill involved.
这不需要什么技巧。
No, it's just yeah That's really funny.
对，就是这样，这真的太搞笑了。
I love the pedicure shot when all five are getting a pedicure because it feels like There's something funny when all five are united in there's no, you know, so much of a TV show or a play or anything is drama and conflict But there's something satisfying about seeing, like, no, we're all going to take a break and get a pedicure together.
我喜欢那个美甲镜头，当他们五个人都在做美甲的时候，因为我觉得当五个人联合在一起时有一种很搞笑的感觉——你知道的，很多电视剧、戏剧或任何东西都是戏剧性和冲突，但看到“不，我们都要休息一下，一起去做个美甲”，这种感觉让人很满足。
Yeah.
对。
In a way, that's what this whole episode was.
从某种意义上说，这整集就是这样的。
There isn't big intra-character conflict, a little bit to you, Marshall, I think that's why it was a little bit hard to write.
这里没有角色之间的大冲突，对你来说有一点点，马歇尔，我想这就是为什么这一集写起来有点困难。
But when we found those moments and those little edit jump cuts, like boom, they're making fun of Barney one second and boom, there they are.
但当我们找到那些时刻和那些小小的剪辑跳接时，就像“轰”，前一秒他们在取笑巴尼，下一秒“轰”，他们就在那儿了。
And the music key on that is very much like this piece, Holiday for Strings, that we always used to use on Letterman for a little bit, like boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
这里的音乐提示很像我们在莱特曼节目中经常用的一段曲子《弦乐假期》，持续了一小段时间，就像轰、轰、轰、轰、轰、轰、轰。
I remember saying to John, so I heard Holiday for Strings, but changing it up that we don't get sued.
我记得我对约翰说，我听到了《弦乐假期》的旋律，但要改一下免得我们被起诉。
That's often a music note.
这通常是一个音乐提示。
But yeah.
不过是的。
But yeah, seeing you guys all together is funny.
不过是的，看到你们大家聚在一起真的很搞笑。
I love when Barney Watson says, I see always in decline, never hitting bottom.
我喜欢巴尼·沃森说：“我看到它一直在走下坡路，从不触底。”
Good to see you old friend.
很高兴见到你，老朋友。
Just this deep relationship.
这种深厚的友谊。
There's so much shitting on Atlantic City in this episode.
这一集里对大西洋城的吐槽也太多了吧。
Yeah.
对。
One of my favorite versions of shitting and what I like about it is there's some shitting on Atlantic City and, you know, take the Atlantic City, there's some shitty stuff about it.
这是我最喜欢的吐槽版本之一，我喜欢的一点是，里面有一些对大西洋城的吐槽，你知道的，接受大西洋城吧，它确实有些很烂的地方。
There's also something adventurous and weird and great about it.
但它也有某种冒险的、怪异的和棒极了的东西。
My favorite shitting on Atlantic City joke in here is where Ted talks about there being a rotting orca on the beach.
我在这里最喜欢的大西洋城吐槽笑话是泰德谈到海滩上有一只腐烂的虎鲸。
There's a rotting orca.
有一只腐烂的虎鲸。
But then there's also the sense of adventure and possibility like they need to find a ship captain and they just do.
但同时也有那种冒险和可能性的感觉，就像他们需要找一个船长，然后他们真的找到了。
It's very original Star Wars.
这非常《星球大战》。
It's like we need a ship captain in this Because we can buy where people are losing their limbs.
这就像“我们需要在这个地方找个船长，因为我们可以买到人们失去肢体的东西。”
I'm a ship cat, oh Han Solo over here, he's a ship cat.
“我是个船长——哦，旁边的汉·索洛，他是个船长。”
So, there is a little bit of AC love of weird adventures happen there, but there's also a routing worker.
所以，这里有点对大西洋城的爱，那里会发生一些奇怪的冒险，但也有腐烂的虎鲸。
There's also something a little bit, like when you're in L.A.
另外还有一点那种感觉，就像你在洛杉矶时——
it's in swingers like let's go to Vegas.
就像在《夺命煞星》（Swingers）里说的一样：“我们去拉斯维加斯吧。”
And you can get there in what, four hours.
而且你大概四个小时就能到那儿。
But in New York, you can't drive to Vegas, but you can get to Atlanta.
但在纽约，你没法开车去拉斯维加斯，但你能去大西洋城。
there's something about the proximity to the city that makes it like you forgive it a little bit for whatever, you know, the rotting orca on the beach because it's close, you know?
某种程度上，因为离城市很近，所以你会稍微原谅它的一些缺点，你知道的，比如海滩上腐烂的虎鲸，因为它离得近，你知道吗？
It's close, it's right there, yeah.
它很近，就在那儿，对。
Like if you have to gamble immediately, you can go there.
就像如果你必须马上赌博，你可以去那里。
Yeah, it's like, yeah, it's like going to like Epcot Center and like, yeah, it's like the countries of the world.
对，就像，是的，就像去未来世界（Epcot Center）一样，就像，是的，就像世界各国。
It's like, I know it's not really the thing but it's kind of a little taste of the thing.
这就像，我知道它不是真的那个东西，但它有点那个东西的味道。
I think we, I remember researching this episode because we're like, they'll go to Atlantic City and they'll get married or they won't get married.
我想我们——我记得在构思这一集时做过调查，因为我们在想，他们会去大西洋城然后结婚，或者他们不会结婚。
By the way, the stakes are you can just go to Atlantic City and get married and we researched it and realized you can't.
顺便说一句，当时的赌注是你可以直接去大西洋城结婚，我们调查后发现其实不能。
Like all those things, at least at the time, that, you know, the clerk woman there, who's also running Kino, she's right.
就像所有那些事情一样，至少在当时，你知道的，那个负责登记的女职员，她还兼营基诺彩票，她是正确的。
Those are all true things.
这些都是真的。
Like you can't just go to Atlantic City and get married and people apparently make that mistake and drive to Atlantic City and realize to their disappointment you can't just do it.
就像你不能直接去大西洋城结婚一样，显然人们会犯这种错误，开车去大西洋城，最后失望地发现你根本不能这么做。
And we thought, remember when we're researching the idea, we're like, oh, I guess bad, that idea doesn't work.
我们当时想——还记得我们在研究这个想法时吗，我们在想，“哦，糟了，这个想法行不通。”
And then we thought, no, that's what's great.
然后我们想，“不，这才是棒的地方。”
Like they have just hurdle after hurdle after hurdle.
就像他们面临着一个又一个又一个的阻碍。
Let's steer into it.
让我们顺应这个设定吧。
Let's steer into the reality.
让我们顺应现实。
You can't just do that.
你就是不能这么做。
So what do they do?
那他们是怎么做的？
How do they come close to getting married?
他们是怎么差点结成婚的？
What's the weird way they got there?
他们用什么奇怪的方式做到的？
So that was the journey.
这就是整个过程。
I loved her line when, I think Lily says, you sure about this and she says about the marriage laws in the state where I work at a wedding chapel.
我很喜欢莉莉说的台词，好像是莉莉说，你确定吗？然后她回答，关于我工作的那个婚礼小教堂所在州的结婚法。
Yeah, I'm sure.
对，我确定。
That was great.
那段太棒了。
I was really pretty delighted with it.
我对此真的相当满意。
It's so funny that when you're on a TV show, if you're the C-story, you feel a little bit like, what did I do wrong last week that they're giving me?
太搞笑的是，当你参演一部电视剧时，如果你是C线剧情，你会觉得有点像，我上周是不是做错了什么，他们才给我安排这个？
So little, they're punishing me this week.
戏份这么少，他们这周是在惩罚我吗？
I always feared that, that's funny to hear.
我以前总是担心这个，听到这话觉得挺有意思。
But as I'm doing this re-watch, I'm noticing that like the C-stories that I'm a part of, B or C-stories are actually hilarious and delightful.
但当我重新看这部剧时，我注意到我参与的C线剧情，B线或C线剧情其实都超级搞笑且引人入胜。
And I like them.
而且我很喜欢它们。
Like this one in particular, you know, we talked about- I love this one.
就像这个特别的桥段，你知道的，我们讨论过——我很喜欢这个。
Marshall, like in that one episode, I think single stamina.
马歇尔，就像在那集里，我觉得是单身耐力。
His whole thing is like, I like fruity drinks.
他整个人设就是，我喜欢水果饮料。
I want a fruity cocktail, you know, and I'm not gonna be ashamed of it, right?
我想要一杯水果鸡尾酒，你知道的，我不会为此感到羞耻，对吧？
That's his entire thing.
这就是他整个人设。
That's it?
就这样？
And in this one, Ted is attracted to Robin in the bikini t-shirt.
而在这一集里，泰德被穿着比基尼T恤的罗宾吸引了。
Like that's his whole- That's all it is.
这就像是他的全部——就这么简单。
That's all it is.
就这么简单。
And I remember, I don't know if props gave me the licorice or if that was in the script, but you know when I'm talking to Robin, I'm just chewing on the licorice.
我记得，我不知道是道具组给了我甘草糖还是剧本里写得那样，但你知道我和罗宾说话时，我嘴里一直在嚼着甘草糖。
It was either court near Gloria.
要么是格洛丽亚附近的那家。
It was either court near Gloria, I remember during one of the runs, just like doubled over, because there's something so like, I don't know, it's almost like how Brad Pitt, they say, is always eating in movies.
要么是格洛丽亚附近的那家，我记得在排练时，笑得直不起腰，因为那种感觉太……怎么说呢，有点像人们说布拉德·皮特在电影里总是在吃东西一样。
There's that bit of like, you just put all, he's always kind of eating as like, did business.
有那么一种感觉，就是你把所有的东西，他总是一边演戏一边在吃东西。
That's really funny, yeah.
真的很好笑，对。
And I felt like there was something really helping me be faux casual by just like, yeah, gnawing on this twizzlers.
我觉得通过嚼着这些甘草糖，这让我有一种假装随意的感觉，真的很有帮助。
Ted's really like, Ted's tapping into his dude energy in this one.
泰德在这集里真的可以说是——泰德展现出了他的纯爷们能量。
He wants to go play Blackjack.
他想去玩二十一点。
He wants to go to the strip club.
他想去脱衣舞俱乐部。
He's eating that piece of liquor as he's, as he's ogling Robin's shirt body, not even her actual body, but it does weirdly kind of turn him on.
他一边吃着那块甘草糖，一边色眯眯地盯着罗宾那穿着T恤的身材，甚至不是她真正的身体，但这奇怪地确实让他有了感觉。
And that, the simplicity of that story, like people on a journey wanting one thing is so it's, That's all it should be.
那种故事的简单性，就像踏上旅程的人只想要一样东西，就是这样，事情本来就该如此。
I want one simple thing.
我只想要一件简单的事情。
It's like the wizard of us.
就像《绿野仙踪》一样。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
The heart, a brain, courage.
一颗心，一个大脑，勇气。
Like you just need, you need to want one simple thing on your little journey.
就像你只需要，在你的小旅程中你只需要想要一件简单的事情。
Then you just get to go on the journey unencumbered, but you have one thing.
然后你就可以无牵无挂地踏上旅程，但你心中有一个目标。
And it's satisfying to watch someone want one thing, you know?
看着别人渴望一样东西会让人感到满足，你知道吗？
Cause we've all been mono-focused.
因为我们都曾极度专注过。
Is that like, like we've all been like zeroed in on like one thing.
就像是，我们都曾像这样死死盯着某一件事情。
And especially like, if you're hungry, you just want one thing, which is food.
尤其是，如果你饿了，你只想要一件事，那就是食物。
If you're horny, you just want one thing.
如果你饥渴了，你只想要一件事。
like we are pretty simple creatures.
我们其实都是挺简单的生物。
It also made me realize like the way that men, especially I'm speaking very broadly, just get so triggered by visual things, you know?
这也让我意识到，男性——尤其是我的发言比较宽泛——对视觉事物是多么容易产生反应，你知道吗？
Like when you do a double take on a mannequin and you're like, that's a mannequin, that's shaped in a way.
就像你对一个人体模特回头看第二眼，然后你想，那只是个模特，它的身材线条……
That's a mannequin, what's wrong with me?
那是个模特，我有毛病吧？
That is designed to trigger me.
那是为了挑起我的欲望而设计的。
But also the way that Kobe Smolders wears that outfit that outfit with such like ease and nonchalance is so funny.
但同时，寇碧·史莫德斯把那套衣服穿得那么轻松自然，真的太逗了。
Like when she just shows up really man.
就像她那样登场的时候，真的。
Where did that come from?
这灵感是从哪来的？
Just having her in that shirt?
就让她穿那件衬衫？
Well, it was it was the we like the idea that Lily is like, you're dressed kind of better than me.
嗯，当时我们就是觉得，莉莉的心态大概是，你穿得比我还要好一点。
You can't be dressed better than the bride.
你可不能穿得比新娘还好看。
I think that Joe Cap and then we're like, okay, what what could Robin go to a cheesy tourist gift shop and walk out wearing?
我觉得是乔·卡普，然后我们在想，罗宾去一家俗气的旅游纪念品商店，会穿着什么走出来呢？
Right.
对吧。
So she dresses down.
所以她打扮得很随便。
So to not outshine the bride.
为了不抢新娘的风头。
Exactly.
没错。
And but the whoever I don't think that was my I maybe that was Maria.
而且——不过不管是——我觉得那不是我的主意，也许那是玛丽亚想的。
It's a great the fact that it's the boot the bikini shirt and he's ogling the cartoon boobs the whole time is really funny.
太棒了，事实上那是比基尼印花的T恤，而且他全程都在盯着卡通胸部看，真的超级搞笑。
That is one of the funniest parts of that episode.
那是那一集里最好笑的桥段之一。
That's a great observation and I hope of like any young actors are listening.
这是一个很棒的观察，我希望如果有年轻演员在听的话。
Sometimes it's a gift to have the simple little thing in the pilot of how Mitch and mother all Barney wants us for Ted to put on a suit.
有时候，在试播集中有一个简单的小细节是一种天赋，就像《老爸老妈浪漫史》里巴尼唯一想要的就是泰德穿上西装。
He has no story.
他没有背景故事。
He has no backstory.
他没有过去的故事。
He has no emotional arc except that is kind of his emotional arc.
他没有任何情感弧光，除了那某种程度上算是他的情感弧光。
He He just wants to be important to Ted.
他——他只是想对泰德来说很重要。
It sort of sets the tone for the whole series, but that's all he wants.
这为整部剧定下了基调，但这也就是他全部想要的。
And when Ted puts on the suit, his story's over.
当泰德穿上西装时，他的故事就结束了。
Yeah, but then it's also like, there was more to him wanting to put on, we didn't know it at the time, but him wanting to put on a suit was connected to like the father he never knew.
对，但同时这也是，他想穿上西装背后还有别的原因，我们当时并不知道，但他想穿上西装其实和那个他从未谋面的父亲有关。
Like nothing is small if you really do your work and interrogate it, you know, and let it live.
就像只要你真正去深入挖掘并剖析它，让它活过来，就没有什么细节是微不足道的，你知道的。
I loved just, I loved when Howie Met and Mother falls into these old, tiny, three stooges kind of grout, like Mark's brother's rhythms, but like, craps, not that nervous.
我太喜欢了，我太喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》偶尔陷入那种老派、微型、像《三傻大闹好莱坞》那样的桥段，就像马克哥哥们的节奏，不过是双关语（craps），没那么紧张。
No, I meant you wanna play craps.
不，我是说你想玩骰子游戏（craps）。
Like, okay.
好吧。
That's a good line.
这台词真棒。
That's like a naked gun.
这就像《白头神探》（The Naked Gun）里的梗。
That's a naked gun joke.
这就是个《白头神探》式的笑话。
It's a very naked gun joke.
这绝对是个《白头神探》式的笑话。
Yeah.
对。
Like once a month, I will laugh out loud by myself, just walking around remembering when Frank Dremen is going through the drawers, when he's snuck in at night to find evidence to prove there's this criminal conspiracy, and he opens a certain drawer in a filing cabinet, he goes bingo and takes that a bingo card.
就像每个月总有那么一次，我会一个人放声大笑，走在路上突然想起弗兰克·德雷宾在翻抽屉的那场戏，当时他夜里潜入进去找证据来证明存在一个犯罪阴谋，他打开档案柜里的某个抽屉，然后大喊“宾果（bingo）”，接着拿出一张宾果卡。
It just holds it up, it just says bingo.
他就把它举起来，上面只写着“宾果”两个字。
It's just, those are things, those are glorious.
就是这样，这些桥段，它们太绝了。
Those moments are glorious and craps that is, that's an airplane neck and a gun joke, basically.
那些时刻简直绝了，而关于craps那个梗，基本上就是一个充满《白头神探》风格的航空笑话。
The humor is the utter literalism of what's in front of you.
这种幽默就在于对眼前事物的绝对字面理解。
It's like not understanding analogy or that things can be two things at once.
这就好比无法理解类比，或者无法理解一件事可以同时拥有两重含义。
Yes, the single entendre.
没错，双关的对立面——单关语。
The single entendre, that's right.
单关语，没错。
Yeah.
对。
That's right.
没错。
It's just, because it's childlike, right?
这只是因为，这种思维很孩子气，对吧？
Like you're not thinking multi-dimensionally, you're thinking one-dimensionally.
就像你不是在用多维视角思考，而是在用单维视角思考。
Yes, and this episode is mostly very simple except for the elaborate Chinese gambling game, which I hasten to point out, the name of that game in Chinese translates in English to deal or no deal.
是的，这一集的大部分内容都很简单，除了那个复杂的中国赌博游戏，我急忙要指出的是，那个游戏名字的中文翻译成英文就是《一掷千金》（Deal or No Deal）。
the show we were losing to in prime time.
也就是我们在黄金时段收视率竞争中输给的那档节目。
Oh, is that right?
哦，是吗？
At the time when this aired in 2006.
在2006年这集播出的那个时候。
So that was like an inside joke?
所以那是个内部笑话？
That was an inside joke to kind of, eh, you know, slightly shit on Deal or No to the absurdity of the, there's a show beating us where it's Howie Mandel pointing to briefcases and then there's money or there's not money in the briefcase.
那是个内部笑话，有点像是在……呃，你知道的，稍微贬低一下《一掷千金》，讽刺那种荒谬性：居然有一档节目收视率压倒我们，内容就是霍威·曼德尔指着公文包，然后公文包里有钱或者没钱。
And that show was like getting millions more viewers than us and we were really upset.
而那档节目的观众比我们多出好几百万，我们当时真的气坏了。
So we said this elaborate game that makes no sense, it comes down to jelly beans and people switching seats.
所以我们才说，这个复杂得毫无道理的游戏，归根结底就是靠果冻豆和换座位。
It's going to be called Deal or No Deal.
它要叫“一掷千金”。
That's how bitter we were.
可见我们当时有多怨念。
It's such a funny thing that the only one who understands it is Marshall because he's the game guy.
太逗了，唯一能看懂的人只有马歇尔，因为他是游戏达人。
Yes.
没错。
It goes back to game night and season one and Marshall, he has this, this savant-like ability to decode really convoluted games.
这可以追溯到第一季的游戏之夜，马歇尔有一种类似天才般的能力，能破解那些极其繁琐的游戏。
And yeah, he's the only person besides the Chinese businessman and Barney that understands how to play this game.
而且，没错，除了那个中国商人跟巴尼，他是唯一一个懂得怎么玩这游戏的人。
I loved how elaborate that game was.
我太喜欢那个游戏的复杂程度了。
There's a giant wheel, there's jelly beans, there's, it's, that was a delight to do.
有个巨大的轮盘，有果冻豆，有，真的，拍那一集太让人享受了。
I love Craig the there's a there's the moment when it's like What is he is he is it the jelly bean in his hand or someone else's hand?
我喜欢格雷格，里面有个镜头是这样的，他到底在干嘛？果冻豆是在他手里还是在别人手里？
Yeah?
是吗？
It's in a woman's hand but they're like a show like they're kind of there's a push in on everyone and everyone is waiting to see There's just that quick thing of Ted is just looking down at Robin's t-shirt It's like blinking you miss it, but he's like not focused on the game.
果冻豆在一个女人的手里，但镜头给所有人推了个特写，大家都在等着看，紧接着就是泰德飞快地往下看了一眼罗宾的T恤。就一眨眼的功夫，你一不留神就错过了，但他当时根本没专心玩游戏。
That is a great little moment Did you find that I wonder if you found that moment and we just added that in I'm not sure if that was written in that's That's that's a that's really funny.
那真是个超棒的小细节。我一直在想，这个细节是你发现的，还是我们后来临时加进去的？我不敢确定这是不是剧本里写的，太好玩了。
Oh, I don't know.
哦，我不知道。
That's a great question.
这真是个好问题。
I don't know if we'll ever know I Know 19 years ago us has the answer.
我不知道我们还能不能找到答案，19年前的我们肯定知道。
Oh my god It's so wild what sticks and what doesn't like you were mentioning that episode and like season seven and I was like I don't remember the main plot you described, but I 100% remember the gag you described Yes, it's weird And memory is really strange, which I suppose is the premise of this entire show, but we're experiencing it as we talk about the show on a podcast, which is even weird.
天哪，什么能留在记忆里，什么记不住，真是太神奇了。就像你刚才提到那一集，第七季的，我说不出你描述的主剧情，但我百分之百记得你说的那个笑点。对啊，太怪了。记忆真的很奇妙，这大概也是整部剧的核心设定吧，不过我们现在是在播客里一边聊剧一边重温这种感觉，这就更奇妙了。
It's the metal levels are stacking up.
套娃的层数越来越多了。
Greg, can I ask you?
格雷格，我能问你个问题吗？
I'm definitely not suggesting you should do any extra research.
我绝对不是在暗示你该去做什么额外的调查。
What do you have from the past?
你还留着过去的什么东西？
What files?
有什么文件？
What history do you have if you wanted to find it?
如果你想找的话，还留着什么历史资料？
I mean, I could probably go back and find we have all the scripts, obviously, but yeah, I didn't keep like an organized like, here's all the notes we got on this.
我的意思是，我大概还能回头去找找，我们当然留着所有的剧本，但是，好吧，我以前没有做过那种很有条理的归档，比如把收到的意见全存好之类的。
If I looked back here, I'll try right now.
如果我在这儿找找的话——我马上试一下。
Ready?
准备好了吗？
Are we Googling live here?
我们这是要在节目里现场谷歌吗？
Atlantic City, episode two, what episode was it?
大西洋城，第二季，那是第几集？
Two, oh, no, two, oh nine?
二零，哦不，二零九？
You said, Alec, or two, oh eight?
你刚才说的是二零几，还是二零八？
Two, oh eight?
二零八？
Episode two, oh eight, notes.
第二季第八集，意见。
I'm gonna do it right now.
我这就来查。
This is John, but this is all staying in the show.
这是约翰干的，不过这些都会留在节目里。
Oh, I got him.
哦，我搜到他了。
Ah, see, I got an oven.
啊，你看，我搜到了一个烤箱。
Atlantic City, come on.
大西洋城，快出来啊。
That's crazy, right?
太疯狂了吧？
Like, this was my email address during the entire show.
这可是我演整部剧期间用的电子邮箱啊。
And Atlantic City doesn't even come up as a fucking concept.
结果“大西洋城”连个屁都搜不出来。
Tell me a story.
给我讲个故事吧。
The other episode we just wrote, we're talking about, uh, that came up.
我们刚写的另一集，我们讨论的那个，刚才也冒出来了。
Oh, wait, you ready?
哦，等等，准备好了吗？
Hang on.
稍等。
I like you'll pull all this together.
我就喜欢你把这些全串起来。
I love this.
我太喜欢这样了。
No, this is perfect.
不，这太完美了。
Oh, I did just find the standards and practices notes.
哦，我还真找到审查和标准部的意见了。
October 19th, 2006, there were none.
2006年10月19日，没有意见。
There was nothing objectionable in this episode said Susie from CBS program practices.
CBS节目审查部的苏茜说，这集里没有任何让人反感的内容。
Hey, Susie, thank you for giving us no notes on that one.
嘿，苏西，谢谢你那集没给我们提意见。
I was hoping to find like network or studio notes, but it's not.
我本来希望能看到类似电视台或制片厂的意见，但并没有。
I found the original outline from Ria Ferrari, August 15th, 2006.
我找到了丽娅·法拉利（Ria Ferrari）在2006年8月15日写的原始大纲。
So that's when Ria the outline first came out.
所以那是丽娅的大纲刚出来的时候。
I found that.
我找到了那个。
Can you just tell us a little, can you read like an opening section?
你能给我们稍微讲讲，能读一下开头的段落吗？
Like what does it sound like in an outline?
比如大纲听起来是什么样的？
What is a scene sound like right now to an outline form?
大纲形式下的场景现在听起来是什么样的？
Yeah, I mean, this isn't how this episode begins.
对，我的意思是，这集并不是这样开头的。
So this said, in cold open, interior little, Ted Marshall's apartment, Lily serves Marshall pancakes in bed.
所以上面写着，冷开场，内景，泰德·马歇尔的公寓，莉莉在床上给马歇尔端煎饼。
They're happy to be out together.
他们很高兴能一起出来。
Lily asks Marshall if being back together means he still wants to get married.
莉莉问马歇尔，重新在一起是否意味着他仍然想结婚。
He does, they start replanting their canceled wedding, quickly realizing what a pain it's going to be.
他是这么想的，他们开始重新筹划取消的婚礼，很快意识到这会有多麻烦。
They already returned the gifts for most of them.
他们已经把礼物退回去了，大部分都是。
Please save the date we mean it this time.
“请空出时间，我们这次是认真的”。
Seems awkward on an invitation.
写在请柬上显得有点尴尬。
Is any of this in the episode, Alec?
这里面有任何内容出现在正片里吗，亚历克？
Mm, I don't think so.
嗯，我觉得没有。
And the new and the new wedding won't be as nice as the old wedding was going to be since they lost all their deposits possible flash to something funny Marshall used the cater or four on their actual wedding date.
而且新的婚礼不会像原本的婚礼那么好，因为他们失去了所有的定金，可能会闪回到马歇尔在他们真正的婚礼日期上用来做餐饮的某个搞笑画面。
This is like an early outline where we had no specifics.
这就像是一个早期的大纲，当时我们还没有什么具体细节。
Wait, had they gotten the Vance Moot House?
等等，他们当时订到万斯·穆特宅邸了吗？
They had and that's and they lost.
他们订到了，而且他们失去了。
Yeah, they lost all this money.
对，他们损失了这么多钱。
I guess I could reuse those ad the, I'm wondering if do we ever explain if they use their suits and most, you'd destroy that wedding dress.
我想我可以用那些广告，我在想，我们有没有解释过他们是否用了自己的西装，而且，你毁了那件婚纱。
So that never came back around.
所以这件事就再也没提过。
They're still in debt from the wedding dress.
他们还在为那件婚纱负债累累。
They're in a huge, huge, whole lily said, wouldn't it be nice if they were just already got married instead of having to face the guests and the families again, which is what the episode really is about, but we probably didn't figure that out enough until later, lily suggests they elope.
他们陷入了一个巨大无比的深坑，莉莉说，如果他们已经结了婚，而不是不得不再次面对宾客和家人，那该多好啊，这其实才是这一集真正的主题，但我们可能直到后来才真正想清楚这一点，莉莉建议他们私奔。
They can drive down to Atlantic City and get married that day.
他们可以开车去大西洋城，当天就把婚结了。
Marshall loves the idea.
马歇尔很喜欢这个主意。
They get more and more excited at the end of this day.
他们越来越兴奋，这一天结束时。
We'll be Mr.
我们将成为先生
And Mrs.
和太太
Marshall, Aldrin Erickson, Marshall, I'm not taking your name.
马歇尔，阿尔德林·埃里克森，马歇尔，我才不随你的姓。
Lily, we can talk about it in the car.
莉莉，我们在车上谈这个。
This is all like, so these are all like plays.
这就像是，所以这些都像是剧本大纲。
This doesn't give you a little sense.
这没能给你一种感觉吗。
It's like placeholder things.
这就像是一些占位符。
We know it's gonna be something like this, but almost none of that, right?
我们知道大概会是这样，但几乎没有哪个部分，对吧？
Is in the actual episode, we changed, basically, everything.
真的在正片里，我们基本上改了一切。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
而这个老人，他必须……我爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在是广告时间。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I often find when I write a script, the first scene I write that I think is like, Oh, this is the central scene of the whole, you know, it almost always gets cut or when you're in editing and you think like, Oh, this is the scene that explains the movie or this is the scene that that also goes away.
我经常发现，当我写剧本时，我写的第一个我认为是“哦，这是整部戏的核心场景”的场景，你知道，它几乎总是会被删掉，或者当你在剪辑时，你觉得“哦，这是解释电影的场景，或者这是那个……”这个场景也会消失。
Like a lot of the ways into the story are not what you end up with.
就像很多进入故事的方式并不是你最终呈现的那样。
Absolutely.
确实如此。
But it's fascinating.
但太迷人了。
You're writing, you're writing a draft to yourself.
你在写，你是在给自己写初稿。
The first draft is always to yourself to figure out what the story is.
初稿永远是写给自己看，用来弄清楚故事到底是什么。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, you're trying, you're just trying to, yeah, you're selling, yeah, that's it.
你知道，你只是在试着，对，你在推销，对，就是这样。
the first person you're selling it to.
你向其推销的第一个人。
You're selling it to yourself to keep writing it.
你是向自己推销，好让自己能继续写下去。
Like, you're writing it for a future you that is going to figure all of these things out.
就像，你是在为未来的那个自己写，那个将把所有这些问题都搞清楚的自己。
And some of that, some of that outline, a lot of the outline often makes the episode, but that was all kind of not really in there.
而且其中一些，大纲中的一部分，很大一部分大纲通常会进入正片，但那些内容当时确实没有真正写进去。
I mean, but the idea is that it is the idea.
我的意思是，但这个想法就是这个想法。
The idea is we don't want to face the family.
这个想法就是我们不想面对家人。
So we're going to run away and it'll just be simple Atlantic City, except it's not simple Atlantic City.
所以我们要逃跑，一切会很简单，就在大西洋城，只不过大西洋城并不简单。
And they realize you can't just run away from your family and that the ritual the like crucible of walking your way through that wedding walking down that aisle and facing the all those eyes right and then saying we are a couple and I you know Lillie's fear that she's going to be reviled by Marshall's family she's like I gotta face this and I thought that was a great that was really when the episode came into focus.
他们意识到你无法逃避家人，那种仪式感——就像走过那场婚礼的历练，走过那条红毯，面对所有的目光，对吧——然后说我们是一个伴侣，而且我（你知道的）莉莉担心她会被马歇尔的家人痛恨，她觉得“我必须面对这一切”，我觉得这太棒了，这才是这一集真正聚焦的时候。
I think I've said this quote on this podcast but there's that quote like that a person often meets their destiny on the road they took to avoid it.
我想我在这个播客里说过这句话，但有这样一句名言：一个人往往在为了逃避命运而选择的道路上与命运相遇。
And it feels like this is like that's it.
感觉这就好像是……就是这样。
That's it.
就是这样。
Yeah.
对。
They're trying to avoid their destiny of like not just marriage but having to live with the perhaps dissatisfaction of, you know, that like, it's not just that Lily feels like, oh, Marshall's family is mad at me.
他们试图逃避他们的命运，不仅是结婚，还要面对可能带来不如意的现实，你知道，这不仅是莉莉觉得“哦，马歇尔的家人对我很生气”。
It's that Marshall is almost defensive like, because everyone's like, we don't want you to get your heart broken again.
而是马歇尔几乎带有防御性，因为每个人都说，我们不想让你再次心碎。
Because boy, did he not have an easy time with that breakup?
因为天哪，他上次分手可一点都不容易。
So there's people who are trying to protect him.
所以有些人是在试图保护他。
But it also feels like in some ways, the judge and the ship captain function as the reminder that they're not getting out of this.
但这也让人觉得，在某种程度上，法官和船长起到了提醒作用，提醒他们是逃不掉的。
Like, what is that?
就像，那是什么？
Like, you can't, you're not going to be able to avoid the discomfort of this.
就像，你不能，你是无法逃避这种不适感的。
And it's actually kind of brilliant.
而且这其实有点绝妙。
Like, it's a great metaphor that we sort of stumbled into that says what you just said, which is they're literally in international waters.
就像，这是一个我们无意中想到的绝佳隐喻，它表达了你刚才所说的，也就是他们字面意义上身处国际水域。
That's how far they're trying to run away from the thing they're trying to avoid.
他们为了逃避想要躲避的事情，跑得就是这么远。
They're in international waters on the janky old ship captains, like boat, whatever that boat is actually used for.
他们在一艘破旧的老船长的船上，身处国际水域，不管那艘船到底是用来干什么的。
I don't know if he's specified, but you can't.
我不知道他有没有明说，但你逃不掉。
You can't run away.
你无处可逃。
They're going to have to face it at some point.
他们总得在某个时刻去面对。
How much further are they going to run farther than the Atlantic Ocean?
他们还能跑多远，比大西洋还远吗？
And there's something nice about accepting their destiny and saying, we're going to be, it's still going to be great.
接受他们的命运并说“我们会，这依然会很棒”是一件很美好的事。
It's still going to be great.
这依然会很棒。
It's going to be great because we walked through fire to get there.
这之所以会很棒，是因为我们历经火海才走到这里。
We walked through all of these things we're trying to dodge.
我们走过了所有这些我们试图躲避的事情。
You know, it occurs to me that when a network says, give us 22 episodes, give us 24 episodes, because I'd say half the seasons we were getting 24 orders, right?
你知道，我突然想到，当一家电视台说，给我们22集，给我们24集，因为我要说有一半的季度他们给我们下达的是24集的订单，对吧？
Like, I think more than not, more than not.
就像，我觉得大多数时候都是这样，超过半数。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
This was still 22 season two, but after that, that I think it became 24 until the strike usually.
第二季的时候还是22集，但那之后，我觉得基本上都变成24集了，直到编剧罢工为止。
So in some ways that the ferocious pay, I just read that Dostoevsky wrote Brother's Caramatsov like for a magazine, like he would do monthly installments.
所以从某种意义上说，那种疯狂的节奏——我刚读到陀思妥耶夫斯基写《卡拉马佐夫兄弟》就像是为杂志写的，他按月连载。
Each chapter was a month, right?
每一章是一个月，对吧？
Yeah, Dickens too, a lot of the Dickens novels, yeah.
对，狄更斯也是，狄更斯的很多小说也是，对。
Shakespeare had produced three plays a season for a company that was depending on him to produce these plays.
莎士比亚一个季度要为一家指望他产出剧本的公司制作三部戏。
I think sometimes deadlines are fantastic motivators for creativity, right?
我觉得有时候截止日期是激发创造力的绝佳动力，对吧？
If you have all the time in the world, you might do nothing.
如果你拥有全世界的时间，你可能什么也做不成。
But if someone's expecting this in their inbox or you better get moving, but there's something about the 22, 24 episode order that both has you lean into absurdity and like, okay, let's get them out of the bar.
但如果有人正等着把东西收进收件箱，或者你最好抓紧时间，不过22集或24集的剧集订单有一种魔力，它既能让你拥抱荒诞感，比如“好吧，让他们离开酒吧”。
Let's get them out of the apartment.
“让他们离开公寓。”
Let's, okay, Atlantic City.
“好吧，去大西洋城。”
Let's have them go back to Minnesota or whatever.
“让他们回明尼苏达或者随便什么地方。”
Some of that stuff can feel like fat, but some of it can actually force you to exercise different narrative muscles, you know, which I think is like, yeah, if this was a 10 episode, 12 episode season, you're not gonna have Atlantic City in here.
其中一些内容可能会显得像是赘肉，但其中一些确实能迫使你锻炼不同的叙事肌肉，你知道的，我觉得这就好像是，如果这是一部10集、12集的剧季，你是不会把大西洋城写进去的。
We wouldn't do it.
我们不会这么做的。
I was thinking the same thing.
我也是这么想的。
It didn't really get you anywhere.
这其实并没有带你走向任何地方。
You couldn't have skipped over.
你没办法跳过去。
That's the sort of flaw of the episode and that's maybe why it was a more difficult rewrite.
这可以说是这一集的一个瑕疵，也许这也是为什么重写它会更困难的原因。
It's really interesting to hear you say, I remember this one was like, five in the morning, this motherfucker comes around and comes out were shooting at 9 a.m.
听到你这么说真的很有意思，我记得这一集是这样的，早上五点钟，这个混蛋就过来了，然后我们早上九点开始拍摄。
I think it's really telling that the episode itself you could lift it out and the story of the season works fine.
我觉得很说明问题的一点是，你可以把这一集单独抽离出来，整季的故事依然运转得很顺畅。
But there's this emotional thing.
但这里面有一种情感层面的东西。
There's emotional commerce happening there.
这里面发生了情感上的交流。
There's something Marshall had to emotionally process that were showing the audience and I think it brings them into those characters, journeys more.
马歇尔有一些必须在情感上去消化的东西，我们把它展现给了观众，而且我认为这让他们更加融入了这些角色的心路历程。
I really think the episode has value.
我真的觉得这一集很有价值。
I like this episode.
我喜欢这一集。
But it's true.
但这也是事实。
I think it wasn't absolutely season plot crucial, right?
我觉得它对整季的主线剧情并非绝对关键，对吧？
That's fair to say.
这样说很公允。
It could lift out.
它是可以被抽离出来的。
But there's something about two things.
但这里面有些关于两点的东西。
One, the central idea of like, okay, we're acting like this is easier than it is.
第一，核心观念就像是，好吧，我们表现得这比实际情况要容易。
But also the fact that Ted and Robin and Barney are along No matter if their families are there, that family's gonna be there.
但同时也是因为泰德、罗宾和巴尼无论如何都在一起，不管他们的家人在不在，那个大家庭都会在那儿。
Yeah.
对。
And it's also a little bit funny, like if you're always trying to create situations where the five of us can be together, a lot of that, one is like, they're best friends, right?
而且也有点好笑，如果你总是试图创造一种让我们五个人能聚在一起的情境，其中很大一部分原因，一是他们是最好的朋友，对吧？
Oh, they're best friends.
哦，他们是最好的朋友。
The other is, you're actually obligated to put us all in the episode, like every episode, you know?
另一个原因则是，你其实有义务把我们所有人都安排进这一集里，就像每一集一样，你知道吗？
So you have to create a context where we all like roll together.
所以你必须创造一个背景，让我们所有人都能一起行动。
Yeah, that's right.
对，没毛病。
That's right.
确实如此。
And I think the Barney gambling thing and the intimation that Barney had this gambling addiction, it's very funny at the end of the boat where he's like, why can't I just do it a little?
而且我觉得巴尼赌博的那段情节，以及暗示巴尼有这种赌博成瘾的问题，在船的最后非常搞笑，当时他说，为什么我就不能稍微玩一下呢？
And like he really, that was another weird element of Barney that we got to explore by thinking of Atlantic City, by thinking they're gonna go there and what is Barney gonna do in Atlantic City?
就像他真的——这是巴尼身上另一个诡异的特质，我们通过想到大西洋城，通过想象他们要在那儿以及巴尼在大西洋城会做什么，从而得以探索。
Well, he's got a gambling addiction.
嗯，他有赌博成瘾。
He's like the fonzi of Atlantic City.
他就像大西洋城的方兹（Fonzie）。
Everyone seems to know him.
似乎每个人都认识他。
He knows the rules of his labored game.
他懂他那种费劲游戏的规则。
Marshall is going to understand the game and Marshall and Marshall alone will understand it because of something we set up in season one It's very cool how things come together like that, right?
马歇尔会理解这个游戏，而且只有马歇尔一个人会懂，因为我们在第一季里做过铺垫。事情能像这样串联起来真的很酷，对吧？
And it's and then what are Ted and Robin going to be doing?
而且——然后泰德和罗宾要干什么呢？
They're just they're a couple They can't have a couple problem the whole episodes about Marshall and Lily's couplehood What's the stupidest thing we could have for them?
他们只是一对情侣。整集都在讲马歇尔和莉莉的伴侣关系，他们俩总不能也遇到情侣问题吧？
It just makes them fun And I like to think we really nailed it It's really one of my favorite parts of the whole episode They literally go have sex in like an Atlantic City municipal buildings broom closet because ramen's wearing a shirt that has nice boobies on it.
我们能为他们安排什么最蠢的事情呢？
It's absolutely absurd.
这只会让他们变得很有趣。我愿意认为我们真的把这部分做得很绝。这绝对是我整集中最喜欢的部分之一。他们竟然在大西洋城市政厅的杂物间里做爱，因为罗宾穿了一件胸部看起来很棒的衬衫。
And Ted somehow woozer into doing this while eating a piece of licorice.
这绝对荒谬至极。
Yeah, that's sexy, sexy piece of licorice.
而泰德竟然一边吃着一根甘草糖，一边把她哄得同意了。
Which is just, it's the sexiest thing a guy can do.
对，那是性感至极的甘草糖。
So it's a very fun episode in the end, but it's sort of, it's a reset.
这简直是一个男人能做出的最性感的事。
I also do think like having Barney, Barney has so many swirling kind of addictions that he does.
所以到头来这是一个非常有趣的剧集，但某种程度上，它也是一次重置。
This is one of the few he calls an addiction, But he's clearly addicted to, you know, women and sex and seduction and he's addicted to buying suits, 100%.
我也觉得，巴尼——巴尼身上有太多盘根错节的各种“瘾”。这是他少数称之为“瘾”的事情之一，但他显然对女人、性和诱惑上瘾，而且他对买西装绝对上瘾。
He has this kind of shopping addiction.
他有这种购物瘾。
He doesn't seem, he doesn't, I've never thought Barney was an alcoholic.
他似乎——他没有，我从来没觉得巴尼是个酒鬼。
Like he looks like he holds his liquor pretty well and it's more of a prop to meet women.
他看起来酒量相当不错，而且喝酒更多只是他用来结识女性的道具。
Yeah, it's part of the thing.
对，这是其中一部分。
But he has all the other addictions.
但他有所有其他的瘾。
Yeah, he really does.
对，他确实有。
He has many, many, the list is very long before you get to alcohol, put it that way.
他有很多很多的瘾，排到酒精之前，那个清单已经很长了，这么说吧。
Yeah, and it's perfect that, you know, the cigars and gambling is just like part of it.
对，而且雪茄和赌博只是其中的一部分，这太完美了。
But it's also like, when he studied, you know, the playbook of someone else, of like, how do you be a man, he, you know, he almost has like a rat pack kind of idea of manhood.
但这也像是，当他研究别人的生存手册时，比如如何成为一个真正的男人，他（你知道的）对男子气概有一种类似鼠党（Rat Pack）的想法。
It's very like 50s kind of what used to be.
非常有那种50年代曾经的风格。
It's like, it's like, he's a real, he's a character out of time in the lot of ways.
这就像是——他是一个在很多方面都与时代脱节的角色。
He wants to be partying with Sinatra, he really is just of that, that's what his brain imagines himself as the main character in a Sinatra film, basically.
他想和弗兰克·辛纳屈（Sinatra）一起派对，他真的就是那种人，他的大脑把自己想象成辛纳屈电影里的主角，基本上就是这样。
We did have a really fun guest star on this episode, a friend of the show, a very good friend of Coby's and Gloria's, who we all love very dearly, Kate Makuchi, who played, we just looked it up, registrar in the news.
我们在这一集里确实有一位非常有趣的客串演员，她是节目的朋友，是科比（Cobie）和格洛丽亚（Gloria）非常好的朋友，我们大家都非常喜欢她——凯特·麦库奇（Kate Micucci）。她扮演了——我们刚查了一下——剧中的登记员。
You're welcome for that juicy part, Kate, as a friend of the show, registrar.
凯特，谢谢你作为节目的朋友来演“登记员”这个多汁的角色。
who were clawing for that part.
（大家都）在为那个角色争破头。
But he is a truly hilarious actor.
但她真是一位极其搞笑的演员。
She's so funny.
她太有趣了。
We should have given her a much longer part, but she's funny in this.
我们本来应该给她安排一个长得多的角色的，但她在剧里已经很好笑了。
Well, she was with Ricky Lindholm.
哦，她和里基·林多姆（Ricki Lindhome）一起组过组合。
They did Garfunkel and Oates, which was, I think on comedy central for a couple of years.
她们搞了“加芬克尔与奥茨”（Garfunkel and Oates），我想这个节目在喜剧中心频道（Comedy Central）播了好几年。
She's so funny.
她太逗了。
A delight.
真是个宝藏。
She came in in this little part and was hilarious and charming within the span of a minute and a half.
她在这个小角色里出场，在短短一分半钟内就表现得搞笑又迷人。
And that's who Kate is.
这就是凯特。
She's just, you get it right away.
你马上就能get到她。
Yeah, she's so great.
对，她太棒了。
So we, I ran into her recently.
所以我们——我最近偶遇了她。
we did a reading of a friend's screenplay, and I said, oh, we have your episode coming up, and would it be okay if we kind of quizzed, you wanna call your memories, or, so Kate was lovely enough to answer a couple of our questions, and we have that audio right here.
我们一起围读了一个朋友的剧本，我说，哦，我们要播到你那一集了，如果我们出点小测验考考你，唤醒一下你的记忆，或者说——行吗？所以凯特非常可爱地回答了我们的几个问题，我们把那段音频放在这里。
Let's play a little of that, Alec.
艾立克，放一小段那个吧。
Hey, Josh, hey, Craig, it's Kate Makucci.
嘿，乔什，嘿，克雷格，我是凯特·麦库奇。
Thanks so much for having me on your podcast to talk about this episode, Atlantic City, baby.
非常感谢邀请我上你们的播客来聊聊这一集，“大西洋城，宝贝”。
I have a few questions that you've asked me, So I'll just go down the line and share my memories as best I can.
你们问了我几个问题，所以我就按顺序来，尽我所能分享我的回忆。
Okay, what are my memories of shooting the show?
好吧，我对拍摄这部剧有什么回忆？
Well, I have a terrible memory, but I do remember being very excited to be on set.
嗯，我的记性很差，但我确实记得当时能去片场非常兴奋。
It's very early on in my career.
那是我职业生涯的早期。
I hadn't done too many things, so it was just exciting to be a part of it.
我没拍过太多东西，所以能参与其中就觉得很令人兴奋。
And also, I'm really good friends with Kobe Smolders, and so it was just exciting to be hanging out with Kobe and meeting all of her co-stars the people she works with on a day-to-day basis.
而且，我和科比·史莫德斯是很好的朋友，所以能和科比一起闲逛，并结识她所有的联合主演——那些她日常共事的人——让我感到非常兴奋。
So that was very exciting for me.
这对当时的我来说非常激动人心。
I don't remember having that haircut, but then I just revisited it.
我不记得自己当时留过那种发型，但刚才我又看了一下。
And wow, that's quite a haircut I have.
哇，我当时的发型还挺特立独行的。
It was a quick scene.
那是一场很快的戏。
It's a quick little pop.
一个很快的客串出场。
And I just remember being like, oh, I wish that had lasted longer.
我只记得当时想的是：哦，真希望拍摄能再久一点。
Which I guess brings me to another question you had, which is what is it like to drop in for two to three lines and then nail it?
我想这正好切入了你们的另一个问题，那就是：只客串两三句台词然后一把过，是什么体验？
Oh, thanks, Craig, for saying that I nailed it.
哦，克雷格，谢谢你夸我“一把过”。
What is it like?
那是什么体验？
It's a lot of pressure because especially something like this where I'm pretty new to acting.
压力很大，因为特别是像这种我刚接触演艺圈的时候。
I haven't been on many shows and then here I am on a successful TV show and I only have a minute to show what I can do and hopefully bring it for everyone who has hired me.
我没演过多少剧，然后突然来到一部成功的电视剧里，我只有一分钟的时间来展现我的能力，并且希望能不辜负所有雇佣我的人。
So yeah, it is always a little bit stressful when you have just a few lines.
所以，是的，当你只有几句台词时，总是会觉得有点压力。
Okay, another question you have, my relationship to how I met your mother.
好的，你们的另一个问题，我和《老爸老妈浪漫史》的渊源。
So I ended up on this episode because my great friend, Gloria Kelder on Kellett, was one of the writers on this episode.
我最终能参演这一集，是因为我极好的朋友——格洛丽亚·卡尔德龙·凯特（Gloria Calderón Kellett）是这一集的编剧之一。
And she said, Katie, come on, I want you to be in this show.
她说：“凯蒂，来吧，我想要你演这个剧。”
And I still had to audition, but I remember auditioning, but no one else was there, so I don't know if it was one of those things that I just kind of had to prove that I could do it, or maybe everyone else had already auditioned, and I came in last minute, I'm not quite sure.
虽然我还是得去试镜，但我记得试镜的时候现场没有别人，所以我不知道这算不算是一种我只需要证明自己能胜任的情况，或者也许其他人已经试镜完了，我是最后一分钟才来的，我其实不太确定。
But yeah, Gloria, thanks to Gloria for bringing me to all of you and it was really fun.
但不管怎样，多亏了格洛丽亚把我带到了你们所有人面前，真的非常有趣。
That's how I ended up on the show.
这就是我参演这部剧的经过。
And actually and through Gloria is how I know Kobe because Gloria would write these plays and then she'd put all her friends in the plays and Kobe was in a play that I had done with Gloria and a bunch of really great actors.
其实通过格洛丽亚我也认识了科比，因为格洛丽亚会写一些戏剧，然后她会把所有的朋友都安排进剧里，科比就参演过我和格洛丽亚以及一群非常优秀的演员合作过的一部戏。
I think a lot of them ended up on how I met your mother at one point or another.
我想他们中的很多人后来都以这样或那样的形式参演了《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And do I get recognized for this role?
我还会因为这个角色被人认出来吗？
I actually do, which is wild, because it's such a short amount of time, but yet people will come up to me and they'll say, I love your episode of how I met your mother.
我还真有，这太疯狂了，因为时间其实很短，但还是有人会走过来对我说，我特别喜欢你在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的那一集。
But I don't know that that's a testament to my performance as much as it is to your show and how wonderful it is and how loyal your fans are.
但我不知道这能在多大程度上证明我的演技，倒不如说是证明了你们的剧有多棒，以及你们的粉丝有多忠实。
And I think that that says a lot about how people who really know your show, people listening right now, They really dive in in such a great way.
而且我觉得这很能说明问题，对于那些真正了解你们剧集的人，也就是现在正在听节目的这些人，他们真的很深入地去了解和喜爱。
So any little nugget, any little tidbit, they'll remember.
所以任何一个小片段、任何一个小八卦，他们都会记住。
So I'm glad I can be one of those little tidbits in this big scope of your beautiful show.
所以我很高兴能在你们这部精彩剧集的宏大背景下，成为那些小八卦之一。
So thank you for having me.
所以谢谢你们邀请我。
Thanks for having me be a part of it.
谢谢让我成为其中的一部分。
Thanks for having me be a part of your podcast.
谢谢让我成为你们播客的一部分。
All right, have a great day, you guys.
好了，祝大家过得愉快。
Thanks so much, bye.
非常感谢，再见。
Thanks so much, Kate.
非常感谢，凯特。
It was so good to hear you, hear your voice on the podcast and such a great little portrait of what it's like to come in, have one small scene for you, really good actor and nail it in this very limited real estate you've been given in this episode.
很高兴听到你的声音，在播客里听到你的声音，这真是一个很好的剪影，展现了客串是什么样的体验——对你这样一个优秀的演员来说，只有短短的一个场景，却能在本集中给你的极其有限的篇幅里大放异彩。
It's a really interesting perspective we haven't had on the podcast yet.
这是一个非常有趣的视角，我们之前在播客里还没聊过。
And we always talk about how we talked about this with Joe, Manganello and like different actors.
我们总是谈到，就像我们和乔·曼根尼罗以及其他不同演员聊过的那样。
Like guest starring is the hardest thing.
客串是最难的事情。
Like dropping into this organism that's already up and functioning and just coming in.
就像空降到一个已经建立并运转良好的有机体中，然后直接加入。
And also generally, you know, she being given like a real big ask.
而且通常来说，你知道的，她被赋予了一个相当大的挑战。
like, there were, there were some twists and turns in her little scene, like just immediately, you know, she did the slalom down a hill and has some sharp turns, but she was amazing.
比如，在她的简短场景中有一些曲折，几乎是立刻，你知道的，她就像在山坡上做回转滑雪一样，有几个急转弯，但她表现得太棒了。
And thank you, Kate.
谢谢你，凯特。
It was really good to hear you on here and see you a couple weeks ago.
很高兴能在这里听到你的声音，几周前还见到了你。
And yeah, we'll, we'll be back with a little bit more.
是的，我们稍后会回来继续。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
We are, we're at a section we like to call general questions, general questions, Alec.
我们现在来到了我们喜欢称之为“常规问题”的环节，常规问题，亚历克。
What it was Right on, wasn't it?
刚才那段挺对味的，对吧？
It's the internet.
这就是互联网。
We always turn on each other.
我们总是互相背刺。
It's the internet.
这就是互联网。
The internet is ruined everything, including our friendship.
互联网毁了一切，包括我们的友谊。
Well, we love to hear from you.
好了，我们很乐意听到你们的声音。
We love your questions.
我们喜欢你们的问题。
We love anything you want to share with us about how you discovered the show, what the show means to you, why you keep watching it, how it's affected your life.
我们喜欢你们想和我们分享的任何事情，关于你们是怎么发现这部剧的，这部剧对你们意味着什么，为什么你们一直看下去，它如何影响了你们的生活。
Please go to howwemadeyourmother.com.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com。
You can also go to quim yim, H-W-Y, wait.
你也可以去 quim yim，H-W-Y，等等。
We HWM, YM, William or howweemayyourmother.com, go to contact and it should be pretty clear about how to send in a question, how to send in a testimonial that we're calling them.
我们是 HWM，YM，William 或者 howweemayyourmother.com，点击“联系我们”，上面应该会很清楚地说明如何发送问题，如何发送我们称之为“听众感言”的内容。
But maybe we'll read your letter at the start of the show, maybe we'll read a letter at the end of the show or area letter at the start of the show rather.
也许我们会在节目开始时读你的信，也许我们会在节目结束时读一封信，或者说，是在节目开始时读一封信。
It's the best part, hearing from you guys is the best part of this whole thing, yeah.
这是最棒的部分，听到你们的声音是整件事最棒的部分，是的。
Please let us know.
请让我们知道。
Also if you're enjoying the podcast, Let your other, how I met your mother, loving family and friends know that we're doing this.
另外，如果你喜欢这个播客，请让你身边的其他《老爸老妈浪漫史》狂热家属和朋友知道我们正在做这个。
We'd love to go through the show with more people.
我们很乐意和更多的人一起重温这部剧。
And Alec, what do you have for us in these questions that are more general?
亚历克，在这些比较常规的问题里，你给我们准备了什么？
I do have, I have a few really good ones for it to say.
我确实有，我有几个非常不错的问题要讲。
I just wanna ask a little bit, let you guys talk about a topic, always worth talking about cheers.
我只是想稍微问一下，让你们聊聊一个绝对值得讨论的话题——《欢乐酒店》（Cheers）。
I just want to point out the sort of vast difference between the way you both were describing this show.
我只想指出你们俩在描述这部剧时表现出的巨大差异。
Josh, you were talking about the 22, the 24 episodes, giving you the pressure and almost the need, the right, to go do something as crazy as, hey, let's all go to Atlantic City.
乔什，你之前提到那22集、24集，给你带来了压力，甚至可以说是赋予了你去做一些疯狂事情的权利和需求，比如，嘿，咱们一起去大西洋城吧。
And Craig, you were talking about the short scenes.
而柯克，你当时在谈论那些短场景。
You felt somewhat more comfortable with the short scenes.
你对短场景感觉更适应一些。
And this defining show for both of you for all of us was basically a 24, 25 minute play in one location that almost never escaped it.
而这部对你们两个、对我们所有人都意义非凡的定义性剧集，基本上就是在一个几乎从未离开过的单一场景里演出的24、25分钟的舞台剧。
And I sort of like hearing, hearing you guys talk about how difficult the this order of this many shows is, makes me just doff my cap ever, ever deeper to cheers and what it was able to do.
我挺喜欢听你们谈论制作这么多集剧集是多么困难，这让我对《欢乐酒店》以及它所成就的伟业，更加肃然起敬、五体投地。
Right.
没错。
Yeah, all in one set.
对，全都在一个布景里。
I mean, it was, it's so hard to write like that.
我是说，这样写剧本太难了。
It's so hard to just like, it's just spotlight up here and then spotlight up 10 minute, you know, 10 feet down the set and then like back you record.
太难了，就好像聚光灯照在这里，然后10英尺（约3米）外的布景又亮起聚光灯，然后……就像录音回放一样。
It's so the artistry of being able to do that.
能够做到这一点的艺术性太高了。
We were much more bells and whistly than that, right?
我们比那种形式要花哨得多，对吧？
Even in this episode, we're jumping locations a lot.
即使在这集里，我们也在频繁更换场景。
We get bored in a hurry, I think, as writers.
我想，作为编剧，我们很快就会感到厌倦。
Carter and I, we wanna move things along and we don't want big talky scenes.
我和卡特，我们想推动剧情发展，我们不想要那种冗长的大段对话场景。
Unless it really matters.
除非真的很重要。
The talky scene has to stand out from the rest for us.
对我们来说，话痨场景必须从其他场景中脱颖而出。
That's always been our recipe.
这一直是我们的秘诀。
Well, I also think Craig, in your defense, I mean, I think you're being a little dismissive of what you and Carter were up to.
好吧，克雷格，我也觉得，为你辩护一下，我觉得你有点轻描淡写了你和卡特当年的所作所为。
It is a show that is memory and the way memory functions is much more nonlinear.
这是一部关于记忆的剧集，而记忆的运作方式要非线性得多。
And, oh, I forgot about this part.
哦，我把这部分给忘了。
And, oh, you know, I think it is that you took the form of it from the convention.
而且，哦，你知道的，我觉得你们确实是从这种传统中汲取了剧集的形式。
Yeah, that's right.
对，没错。
You don't, your memories aren't like, here's the entire conversation we had, right?
你不会觉得，你的记忆就像是我们曾经进行过的整段对话，对吧？
You remember a snippet.
你只记得一个片段。
You remember one little bit and then it jumps ahead and everything in between and your memory is kind of hazy.
你记得一个小细节，然后它就跳过了，中间的一切以及你的记忆都是有点模糊的。
So your mind edits it and jumps as a flash forward.
所以你的大脑会对其进行剪辑，像闪回一样跳转。
And you say, oh, I left out this part.
然后你说，哦，我漏掉了这一段。
I think you go back.
我想你得倒回去。
I left out this part.
我漏掉了这一段。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Yeah.
对。
And it fit that storytelling form fit our brains really well.
这种叙事形式非常契合我们的大脑。
That's how we think.
我们就是这样思考的。
You guys were also I remember on an enormous amount of cocaine, I think during that year.
我记得你们俩当年也磕了巨量的可卡因，大概就在那一年吧。
Huge.
海量。
I mean, I still am right now.
我是说，我到现在还在磕呢。
We have a great, pretty simple question that I actually have the answer to.
我们有一个很棒、很简单的问题，其实我知道答案。
Don't worry about it.
不用担心。
From Jessica Wallace, XOX, who asks a lot of great questions, hi, Jessica.
来自杰西卡·华莱士（Jessica Wallace，XOX），她经常提出很多很棒的问题，嗨，杰西卡。
He asks, how much do extras get paid that are just in the background and have no lines?
她问，那些只在背景里出现、没有台词的群演能拿多少片酬？
We actually co-producer Doug looked that up and today as a background actor for eight hours, you'd get $244 and for 12 hours, $392.
我们的联合制片人道格实际上查过这个，如今作为一个背景演员，工作8小时可以拿到244美元，工作12小时则是392美元。
All right.
好吧。
I would have had no answer for that.
我本来完全答不上来。
You know what I was always touched by is, especially in the bar, well, some of the background actors were there for years and we got to know them, you know, and it was awesome.
你知道我一直以来觉得很感人的是什么吗，特别是在酒吧里，有些背景演员在那儿呆了好多年，我们都和他们混熟了，你知道的，这太棒了。
But sometimes you'd see like someone with like a college textbook and be like, oh, these are UCLA students who live in Westwood that are studying on set and just making a couple extra bucks.
但有时候你会看到有人拿着大学教科书，就会想，哦，这些是住在韦斯特伍德的UCLA学生，他们一边在片场学习，一边顺便赚点外快。
And I always thought that was like such a good kind of little additional day job for a college student to kind of, especially living in LA, you can do that.
我一直觉得，这对大学生来说是一个非常棒的兼职副业，尤其是在洛杉矶生活，你完全可以这么做。
And whenever any friends or family would visit any of the cast or people who worked on the show, they would be unpaid background extras.
每当有任何演员或剧组工作人员的朋友和家人来探班时，他们都会去当没有片酬的背景群演。
I know a lot of, my son was in the background one time, my wife.
我知道很多人，我儿子有一次就在背景里出镜过，还有我妻子。
Oh, I have friends who are in episodes that still get flagged from it, yeah.
哦，我有朋友客串过剧集，现在偶尔还能被人认出来呢，对。
Well, very confusingly, Todd does show up in the bar throughout season nine or so.
嗯，非常令人困惑的是，托德确实在第九季左右的酒吧里出现过好几次。
I'm sitting there for something or other.
我当时就坐在那儿干嘛来着。
Oh my God, you were brought back into Alec as a reference.
天哪，亚历克，你竟然被当作梗给带进来了。
I mean, not that you have to explain your character, but Alec's character was that I mean everyone.
我是说，倒不是说你必须解释你的角色，但亚历克饰演的角色就是……我是说每个人。
Favorite Todd.
最爱的托德。
fan favorite Todd from Best Prom Ever, is that him?
来自《史上最佳舞会》的粉丝最爱托德，那是他吗？
Best Prom Ever.
《史上最佳舞会》。
Okay, so Doss Superboil says Atlantic City has such a presence in the show's run, are Carter and Craig Gambler's.
好吧，所以 Doss Superboil 说大西洋城在该剧的播出期间有着如此重要的存在感，卡特和克雷格是赌徒吗？
No, not at all.
不，完全没有。
We did go to Atlantic City for super weird bachelor party of a Letterman writer friend at one point.
我们确实去过一次大西洋城，是为了一个莱特曼编剧朋友举办的超级奇葩的单身派对。
And for, why am I saying it that way?
而且为了……我为什么会这么说？
We went to that first and then also for mine, after a year or two after, but Alec was at, which was just as embarrassing and weird as you might imagine, very stupid, but fun.
我们先是去了那个派对，后来一两年后又为了我的派对去了，但亚历克也在，就像你想象的那样尴尬和诡异，非常蠢，但也很有趣。
I mean, it's like Atlanta said you get there and you're aware that it's not Vegas, it wants to be Vegas, it's not Vegas, and there's comedy in how not Vegas it is.
我的意思是，就像亚特兰大说的，你一到那里就会意识到这不是拉斯维加斯，它想成为拉斯维加斯，但它不是，而它“不像拉斯维加斯”这一点本身就很搞笑。
But you do wind up getting kind of into it and having fun.
但你最后还是会慢慢融入进去并觉得挺好玩的。
So we did, hopefully we didn't shit on Atlantic City too much.
所以我们去了，希望我们没有把大西洋城贬得太厉害。
Atlantic City is the not Moby to Vegas is Moby.
大西洋城之于拉斯维加斯，就像……非莫比之于莫比。
It's like, wait, is it?
等等，是这样的吗？
No, it's not even close.
不，完全不是这回事。
It is the non-moby, it's the non-moby.
它是“非莫比”，它是“非莫比”。
Well, clearly we had too much fun because I briefly forgot that we went there for my, I love when I started with, oh yeah, I went there once for my friends, that's a funny, oh yeah, and mine too.
好吧，很明显我们玩得太开心了，以至于我刚才短暂地忘了一开始去那是为了我的……我最喜欢我一上来就说，“哦对，我以前为我朋友去过一次，真搞笑，哦对，我自己的那次也是。”
I literally, that's clearly there was some drinking involved.
我真的……很明显当时喝了点酒。
I feel though that we smoked cigars like a decent amount on the show and I feel like that came from Carter.
不过我觉得我们在剧中抽雪茄的频率还挺高的，我觉得这得归功于卡特。
Carter, I just feel like, has more of a smoking jacket, cigar, kind of, and an old fashioned, you know what I mean?
卡特给我的感觉就是，更有那种吸烟夹克、雪茄的调调，还有一杯老式鸡尾酒，你知道我的意思吗？
He's got this kind of like, he's a little more in those, right?
他就是有那种感觉，他更偏向于那种风格，对吧？
He likes, I think he likes every now and again, sort of being like that, but he's not really, he's not smoking cigars.
他喜欢，我想他偶尔会喜欢表现得那样，但他其实并不是那种经常抽雪茄的人。
Through the whole run of the show, whenever we smoked cigars, 9.30 in the morning, it was always, never at night, it was always so early.
整部剧拍下来，每当我们要抽雪茄的时候——早上9点半，总是选在白天，从来不在晚上——总是那么早。
And Dave Baker was good at smoking cigars, and Neil was actually quite good at smoking cigars and better than me, but I would always have to say, Dave, show me again, like I just wasn't.
而且戴夫·贝克很会抽雪茄，尼尔其实也非常擅长抽雪茄，比我强，但我总是不得不说：“戴夫，再教我一次。”因为我就是学不会。
It's like a life, that's something, it's a life choice.
这就像是一种生活方式，这是个选择。
You're either a guy who decides to really learn that and really look okay doing it or you're, there's no middle ground, I feel.
要么你是一个决定真正去学并且抽起来很好看的人，要么就是……我觉得没有中间地带。
And I never really learned how to do it.
而我从来没有真正学会怎么抽。
You probably had to cut away when I was smoking the cigars.
我抽雪茄的时候，你们可能不得不把镜头切走。
It's not my great talent.
这不是我的强项。
I would say that as a category, the number one type of question we get is about improv.
我要说的是，从类别来看，我们收到最多的问题就是关于即兴表演的。
And we've talked about this a lot.
我们已经讨论过很多次了。
We have clarified, you have clarified.
我们澄清过，你也澄清过。
The show is not improvised.
这部剧并不是即兴表演。
We've talked about Josh's great and mailed it.
我们说过乔什表现得很棒，完美驾驭了角色。
And- There was some.
而且——确实也有一些。
I mean, there was some- And the idea that there were some.
我是说，确实有一些——而且那种认为有即兴的想法……
I mean, the way this question was asked, actually by Jessica, yeah, hi, Jessica.
我是说，提问的方式其实是杰西卡问的，对，嗨，杰西卡。
Is the game scene improv to make things as confusing as possible or was it all scripted out?
游戏环节的场景是为了把事情搞得尽可能的混乱而即兴发挥的，还是完全按剧本写好的？
No, you can only make it insane if you plan it.
不，只有在精心策划的情况下，你才能把它搞得这么疯狂。
It has to be very meticulously planned to make no sense.
必须经过极其缜密的策划，才能做到完全不知所云。
That's the paradise.
这就是妙处所在。
Because everyone, everyone playing it is unified in terms of knowing the rules.
因为每个人，每一个参与其中的人在了解规则这方面都是高度一致的。
The order of events has to be in stone.
事件的先后顺序必须是板上钉钉的。
I will say, Alec, I think that this question is a compliment, which means there's something that feels very lifelike and spontaneous about the show.
不过我要说，亚历克，我觉得这个问题其实是个夸奖，这意味着这部剧里有些东西让人感觉非常真实和自然。
But the reason, like Craig is saying, like the reason it feels that way is because it's quite well mapped.
但就像克雷格说的，之所以会有这种感觉，是因为剧本规划得相当好。
Yeah.
对。
You know.
你知道的。
It's a compliment to the cast.
这是对演员阵容的夸奖。
Cause you make it seem very naturalistic and the truth is there wasn't much improv.
因为你们把它演得非常自然，但事实是并没有多少即兴表演。
Like we were just, we had, we had Cobion a few episodes ago talking about slap bed and the very ending of that episode where the whole gang is watching the video, the music video on Barney's laptop.
就像我们……几集前科比来的时候聊到过“打耳光床”，那一集的最后，整帮人在巴尼的笔记本电脑上看着那个音乐录影带。
I remember that was like, you guys were riffing a little there.
我记得那是……你们当时在那儿稍微即兴发挥了一下。
Like, I think we fed you some lines and you were riffing and that had a little bit of a different feel.
好像是我们喂了你们一些台词，然后你们顺着即兴发挥，那段感觉确实有点不一样。
But that's, that's rare.
但那很少见。
It's very rare.
非常罕见。
And to make something as stupid as that intricate gambling game that makes no sense, so much work in planning goes in that.
为了做出像那个莫名其妙、毫无逻辑的复杂赌博游戏那么蠢的东西，前期需要投入大量的工作和筹划。
That's my favorite thing.
这就是我最喜欢的部分。
how much work goes into creating something super, super stupid.
为创造超级无敌蠢的东西投入了多少心血。
That is one of my favorite just brands of comedy.
那是我最喜欢的喜剧风格之一。
But when something feels chaotic and insane, usually a lot of planning went into it.
但当某个东西让人感觉混乱和疯狂时，通常背后都经过了大量的筹划。
It just seems like, I mean, no show really in the, your Euro is sort of when that notion started, that there might be a lot anywhere from a little bit to a lot of improv.
这似乎……我是说，在你们那个年代，没有哪部剧会真正有这种观念——即从一点点到大量的即兴发挥。
I think we got out the idea that in the office, certainly when you go and you watch the outtakes, it seems like Steve Carell is making up a lot of stuff as he's going on to just keep going and keep going and keep going with that style.
我想我们都有一种印象，在《办公室》里，特别是当你看花絮时，感觉史蒂夫·卡雷尔在不断地即兴发挥，好让那种风格持续下去、继续、继续、再继续。
But this stuff is pretty tightly scripted.
但这部剧的剧本是非常严密的。
We had to shoot in three days, you know, the office is probably a five day shoot.
我们必须在三天内拍完，你知道的，《办公室》大概需要拍五天。
And even that they would have to limit it.
即便如此，他们也得有所限制。
Like these movies like Judd Apatow movies and movies were like, Oh, the actors just go and go and go and go.
就像贾德·阿帕图的那些电影，人们会说：“哦，演员们就一直在那儿即兴演个不停。”
You just can't do that in TV.
你在电视上根本做不到这一点。
There's just no time.
根本没有时间。
You have to finish shooting, edit it and get it on TV in a week.
你必须在一周内完成拍摄、剪辑并搬上电视播。
Like it's there's not enough time.
时间根本不够。
And because of the way the show was structured, it's just so intricate.
而且因为这部剧的结构方式，它是如此的错综复杂。
It's just, it's not a lazy porch, you know, shooting the shit kind of show.
它绝不是那种懒散的、闲聊扯淡式的剧。
It's like, you know, you have 40 to 60 scenes, you gotta move.
而是那种，你知道的，你有40到60个场景，你得抓紧拍。
Yeah.
对。
Let's see what we come up with on the fly.
让我们看看现场能临场发挥出什么。
It's, you can't do it.
根本做不到。
You have 10 minutes to shoot all the scene.
你只有10分钟来拍完整场戏。
Well, just as a last question here, Terry ODO2 just wants to point out how great the song sync to the bottom with you was just want to talk a little more about that music choice as we end this episode.
好吧，作为最后一个问题，Terry ODO2 只是想指出，在这一集的结尾，与你同步的歌曲《Sink to the Bottom》有多棒，随着我们结束这一集，我们想再多聊聊那个音乐选择。
Yeah.
对。
I was so excited.
我当时太兴奋了。
That was, that was me.
那是……那是我的主意。
That was my choice because I love that song.
那是我的选择，因为我太喜欢那首歌了。
I love that man.
我太喜欢那个人了。
Fountains of Wayne, Adam Schausinger, RIP.
喷泉之韦恩乐队（Fountains of Wayne）的亚当·施莱辛格（Adam Schlesinger），安息吧。
Very, very sadly, lost him during COVID.
非常、非常令人痛心的是，我们在疫情期间失去了他。
Such a talented, brilliant, melodist.
如此才华横溢、才思敏捷的旋律大师。
Is that a word?
这是一个词吗？
Melodist?
旋律大师？
The melody writer, he's just like, he is, he is a Beatles caliber melody writer.
那个写旋律的人，他简直就像……他拥有披头士级别的旋律创作水准。
And they were says, founds of Wayne, such a great band.
他们就是喷泉之韦恩乐队，一支太棒的乐队。
And yeah, I was just a huge fan of that song.
是的，我只是那首歌的超级粉丝。
I love that song.
我太爱那首歌了。
I play that guitar a little bit and play for my son and stuff.
我会弹一点吉他，会弹给我儿子听之类的。
And we, it just felt like it fit.
然后我们……就觉得它非常契合。
It's like this tortured love song, right?
就像是一首备受折磨的情歌，对吧？
It's at this moment where Marshall and Lily are saying, let's crawl through the Shawshank sewer pipe of our judgmental family's eyes.
正是在那个时刻，马歇尔和莉莉说：“让我们穿过那些对我们评头论足的家人的眼光所构成的肖申克下水道管道吧。”
And let's go through all the things we're dodging.
“让我们去面对所有我们一直在躲避的事情。”
like, we'll go through this crucible of all of Marshall's family is going to think Lily's the runaway bride and scowl at her for breaking Marshall's heart a few months back.
就像，我们要经历这样一番严峻考验：马歇尔的家里所有人都会觉得莉莉是落跑新娘，并且因为几个月前莉莉碎了马歇尔的心而对她怒目相向。
And she says, let's do it anyway, because that's, that's how we really get married.
而她说，不管怎样我们都要这么做，因为这才是我们真正结婚的方式。
And that song, sink to the bottom with you.
而那首歌，《Sink to the Bottom with you》（与你沉入海底）。
I will sink to the bottom with you.
我愿意与你一同沉入海底。
I will go in with you, even if it might mean we were going to go all the way to the bottom of the ocean together.
我愿意和你一起跳进去，哪怕这意味着我们最终会一起沉到海洋的最深处。
I'll still do it.
我依然愿意这么做。
It just, it feels like it fit the tone of like, sometimes that's marriage, right?
这感觉就像……这很符合那种基调，婚姻有时不就是这样的吗？
Sometimes that's couplehood.
有时的确就是两个人的相伴。
You got to sort of sink to the bottom together.
你们得一起沉到谷底。
So I was really happy to get that song on there.
所以我很高兴能把那首歌放进剧里。
And it had really moved me hearing it again for the first time since Adam Sussinger died.
自从亚当·苏辛格去世后，再次听到这首歌真的让我很触动。
And yeah, just what a talent.
而且，真的是个很有才华的人。
So it was great to get his music on there.
所以能把他的音乐放进去太棒了。
Craig, it's always such a pleasure to dive into these episodes with you.
克雷格，每次能和你一起深入探讨这些剧集总是让人非常享受。
Alec, Doug, Alex.
亚历克，道格，亚历克斯。
I love you guys.
我爱你们。
It really does have the feeling of like looking through an old photo album and and be like, oh my God, I totally forgot about that night.
这真的有一种翻看旧相册的感觉，然后会感叹，天哪，我完全忘了还有过那个夜晚。
That was insane, you know?
那太疯狂了，对吧？
It's really like, it's such a fun stroll down memory lane.
真的就像是一次非常有趣的美好回忆之旅。
And not many people have this much of their, you know, 30s document, like this was before everyone started recording everything.
而且没多少人像我们这样记录了30多岁的时光，这可是在每个人都开始随手录像的时代之前。
Like we really do have this living photo album of us at a time in our lives that it's pretty extraordinary.
我们确实拥有了一本关于我们人生某个阶段的活生生的相册，这相当了不起。
And it looks great at the ending of that episode.
而且那一集的结尾看起来很棒。
It's all of them out on this boat with the sun setting over the horizon.
他们所有人都在一艘船上，夕阳在天边落下。
Of course, it's just, it's a really good blue screen.
当然，这其实是一个非常棒的蓝幕合成。
It's obviously, it's just, it's beautifully done.
很显然，这只是制作得非常精美。
Like, our team is amazing to make that look that good.
我们的团队太厉害了，能把效果做得这么好。
In the production point and in post, it looked like a really beautiful moment with all of these guys floating out on the Atlantic Ocean and with the sun setting, and it really works.
从前期制作到后期，看起来就像是一个非常美好的时刻，所有这些人在大西洋上漂流，伴随着夕阳西下，效果真的很好。
There was something really gorgeous about that.
那里面有一种非常美妙的东西。
Marshall, you're gonna go back to land and go face the music of actually getting married.
马歇尔，你要回到陆上去面对真正结婚的现实了。
It's a great sort of mid-season, right?
这算是一个很棒的中季过渡，对吧？
We're right about at the mid-point, coming up on the mid-point of season two, but it launches, it helps get you into that next push, which is gonna be getting them really married.
我们差不多正处于第二季的中间，即将迎来中点，但它开启了新的一段，帮你顺利推进到下一阶段，也就是他们真正要结婚的时候。
So it's a good one.
所以这是一个很好的节点。
This is fun to talk about and revisit.
聊这些并重温这些真的很有趣。
Just because I'm the resident, since I'm the resident quote guy, I think we can all agree, I'm the resident quote guy.
既然我是剧组的名言达人，我觉得大家都会同意，我是那个名言达人。
You're the quote guy, sure.
你是名言达人，行吧。
Quote master.
金句大师。
I think Isaac Dinnison has a line that I've always loved that said the cure for anything is salt water, sweat, tears, or ocean.
我觉得伊萨克·迪内森有一句我一直很喜欢的话，她说任何事情的解药都是：盐水、汗水、泪水或大海。
That's a great observation.
这是一个很棒的洞察。
And I feel, you know, they get, they head to the ocean, but no, you know, normally it's like, you should get in the ocean, but they were just on, they were a top it, and, and they got their, they got their answer.
我觉得，你知道的，他们去了海边，但并不是那种，你知道的，通常情况下，别人会说“你应该去海里”，但他们当时就在海面上，然后，他们得到了他们的答案。
Yeah.
是的。
It's our Moby Dick.
这是我们的白鲸。
It's our Moby Dick moment.
这是我们的“白鲸”时刻。
The wedding is the way to well.
婚礼就是那条鲸鱼。
Not, not Moby Dick.
不是，不是白鲸。
Not Moby Dick.
不是白鲸。
Hey, yeah.
嘿，对。
Not Moby Dick.
不是白鲸。
Oh, it doesn't get any better than that.
噢，没有比这更好的了。
And that's like a smartless buy.
这简直像个“聪明人”的经典失误。
Not Moby.
不是白鲸。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请把我拖出去处决吧。
All sins are forgiven.
所有罪孽都已免除。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies网络和奥德赛（Audacy）公司呈现并发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是蓝色之点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面美术由约翰·莫罗设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
at HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的简报，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
请在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《事情可不是这样的》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他的其他出版作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死父亲协会”专栏。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何为本节目筹集先天性儿科心脏病研究资金的持续公益活动贡献力量的信息，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上是会跳舞的。
Real question, it just hit me, or just New York City.
有个真问题，我突然想到的，还是说只有纽约市才会这样。